- Mugs.
"Trash Taste" mugs.
- You know who's not a mug?
You.
(Joey laughs)
- Wow, love this mug.
I love the lid that it comes with
and how well built it is
and handcrafted the mug is.
- But unfortunately, boys,
there's only one week left to get this.
(Connor sobbing)
I know.
Seven whole days left for you
to grab the "Trash Taste" mugs
by going to trashtastemugs.com.
And once those seven days
are up, the mugs are more.
- I'd regret it if I
didn't have the chance
to buy one of these mugs.
- It's almost the perfect size mug
for any kind of beverage.
Beer, tea, coffee, water, urine.
Anything you can imagine
that you'd like to drink,
you can contain in this mug.
- So if you love "Trash Taste"
and you wanna support the boys,
trashtastemugs.com.
- I would feel like such a
mug if I didn't buy this.
(Joey and Garnt laughs)
Buy it, buy it now.
- Trashtastemugs.com
Buy it, buy it.
- One week left.
Get them now.
Link's in the description.
- Buy it, buy it now.
- Back to the episode.
(Joey groans)
- Squirted all over myself.
- Hell yeah, you did.
- Always happens to me.
- Just nutted on myself.
- Gonna nut.
(gentle music)
- What up, squad.
Welcome back to another episode
of the "Trash Taste" podcast.
I'm Joey and I'm with the boys.
- Well, that was the most
depressing intro we've had yet.
(Garnt laughs)
- Wait, what do you mean?
- "I'm with the boys." (groans)
- Yeah.
- We could lay a bit
more build-up than that.
- Didn't even have any pre-talk there.
We just, like-
- Hey, guys. (laughs)
Welcome to "Trash Taste."
- I didn't even know we were recording.
I was like, "Oh, wait, is the
lights on? Are we rolling?
Are we rolling?"
(Joey laughs)
- I feel like, "Dora the Explorer" energy
as opposed to "Clockwork Orange" energy.
- Did you want "Dora the Explorer" energy?
Aright, I'll give you
"Dora the Explorer" energy.
Hey, everybody.
It's time for "Trash Taste" podcast.
Are you ready?
- [Garnt] Hold on, I need coffee.
- Good.
- Hold on, I need a bit more
time for this coffee to sink in
from these amazing mugs
that we're drinking out of
right now.
- Is that a "Trash Taste" mug?
- Well, we've already been
promoting them by this point,
but we are actually drinking out of them.
- Yeah, we're drinking
out of them for once.
- Yeah, these are the first batch though
so the lid's a little too big.
But the ones that you
guys will be drinking from
won't have a big ass lid.
- Yeah, the lid will fit a lot better.
But I really like these mugs.
I mean, we've already promoted them.
You already know. You already
know what we're talking about.
- It's a "Trash Taste" mug.
- We don't know how good
or bad it did. (laughs)
(Garnt laughs)
Or it's like, eh.
- Maybe everyone hates them
and this is like a poorly
aged bit, I don't know, like-
(everyone laughs)
- Poorly aged episode.
But it's been roughly two weeks, I think,
since we all gathered last time.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it feels a lot longer.
Like two weeks without the boys?
Jesus. I don't know how I went so long
without seeing you guys so often
before we moved to Japan.
- Yeah, right?
- Like, what, it just feels
like a part of my life
has just been taken away from me
just because I didn't record a podcast.
- 'Cause I think last time I saw Connor,
we were getting our second shot.
- On my birthday.
- Yeah, which felt like a month ago.
- Yeah, that was like a week ago though.
- God, how fucked were you
guys with that second shot?
- I was very sick, very sick.
- Can we just talk about that?
- Yeah, yeah.
- The 5G, it was, yeah.
- Yeah, the 5G.
- So for the record,
we got Moderna shots.
- Yep.
- So did you guys feel
anything for the first shot?
- Ah, well, I had that
like, lower back pain
for some reason.
- Oh, yeah,
we did talk about that, didn't we, yeah.
- And I was like, I mean,
obviously, you know,
the arm that we got the shot
hurt like a motherfucker.
- It was a bit sore.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But for some reason,
only Aki and I got this
really bad lower back pain
for some reason.
- I got it on the second dose.
- You got it on the second dose?
- Yeah, my lower back was hurting all day.
- Didn't it feel like
someone just drop-kicked you in the back?
- It was more of like an uncomfortable.
- Oh, really?
- Like if someone was, like,
poking my back constantly.
and I couldn't get it.
I didn't know why.
It was very frustrating.
- Oh, mine was like
if someone was fucking doing that
to my lower back just constantly.
It's like, no.
(Garnt laughs)
- Maybe when you and Aki are sleeping,
she wakes up and just
does like WrestleMania.
(Joey laughs)
And then vice versa when-
- She practices elbow drops
as I'm sleeping.
(Garnt and Connor laughs)
- Ladybeard just invades your dream,
and just like, ah. (laughs)
- Ah, ah.
- Maybe you passed Ladybeard
in the hallway, you know?
- Oh, yeah, the chat energy
pulled my back out. (laughs)
- It's like "Nightmare
on Elm Street," right?
(Joey laughs) Like, anything
he does in your dreams
just affects you in real life.
(Garnt and Joey laughs)
- Oh, Jesus.
- Freddy Krueger just
came out from the bed,
stabbed me in the back.
(Garnt laughs)
- I had a fantastic birthday,
celebrating by being sick in my home.
- Oh, yeah.
- Yeah.
- It was beautiful birthday.
- 'Cause we all shared on our
line a message that we have,
like, what the temperature
of everyone's was.
Yours was through the fucking roof.
- Yeah.
- You were like 39 degrees.
- Yeah, it shot up to like 39.
- I was like,
"Is this the last time
I'm gonna see this man?
- 39?
- That's what it was, yeah.
- Oh, fuck, I didn't
realize it went that high.
- It was actually dangerous levels.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I didn't feel like I was sick
when I woke up.
- Really?
- When I woke up, I was like, "Wow,
it's just kinda hot, isn't it?"
(Garnt laughs)
- Oh, really?
- It's little bit spicy in here.
- (laughs) That's kind of
what a fever is, you know?
- Well, I didn't particularly feel bad.
I've had fevers before
where I felt really sick
and I didn't feel good,
but this one, I was just like,
"Wow, I'm just really hot."
- Yeah.
- Oh, really?
- Wow. And then I got out of bed
and I went to take my temperature
and I was like, "Oh, it's high."
It's high.
- Yes.
Oh, I'm cooking from the inside.
That's probably why.
- And then I was like, "Okay,
I'm gonna go and get some
energy drink from the store."
Er, not energy drink.
Like Gatorade or whatever, you know,
just like the generic water-
- Yeah, I was gonna say,
Red Bull is probably not the best thing
to be drinking on a fever.
- Water.
It's literally just any drink
that's water featuring sugar.
You know those drinks.
- Yeah.
- Like Pocari Sweat, something like that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I got it.
And then by the time I got home,
I was like, "Okay, now I
actually think I feel sick now."
- [Joey] Oh, right.
- I think I feel pretty shitty.
And so I didn't do
anything on my birthday.
- I think it's the opposite
for me. I immediately woke up
and all of my joints were
just aching like crazy,
but it was weird because
I checked my temperature
and I only had like, 37 or something,
so I only had like a slight fever,
but, man, my bones were just rattled.
- Yeah, it was really weird for me
because I woke up and
I felt completely fine.
I woke up to, like, we
have like a group chat
where all the staff
members of "Trash Taste"
were just like, "Are we recording today?"
And everyone posted their temperature
and were like, "No, we're
definitely not recording today."
- [Joey] Nope. (laughs)
- No, that's not a thing that's happening.
And then I took my temperature
and mine was just like, 37 on the dot.
And I was like, yeah,
I feel completely fine.
And got up, started doing work,
being like, "Oh, these guys
just have weak immune systems."
(Joey laughs)
- Got up like Zen.
- Yeah, yeah. (laughs)
- Can you imagine having
weak immune systems?
And then fucking two o'clock rolls over,
I'm sitting at my computer,
I'm like, "Ooh, I'm getting chills.
What's happening here?
What's happening here?"
- (laughs) Serves you right.
- Yeah, yeah.
And then I went from
being completely fine,
to just having the worst headache
and just properly just having the flu.
So I'm just like, "Man, this
is vaccine's got hands, man."
It's fucking fighting, man.
- (laughs) This is a
bit delayed, wasn't it?
- Yeah. (laughs)
- Yeah, it was a bit delayed.
So, yeah, in the end, I
woke up completely fine,
and then for most of
the day after 2:00 p.m.,
I was just completely bedridden.
- Oh, yeah.
- Yeah.
- How long were you guys in bed for?
- I don't know, I was
watching the Olympics.
You know, just chilling.
- Oh yeah.
- Just watching people do sports.
And I was like, "Wow, that could be me.
That could be me right now."
- I still haven't seen
anything from the Olympics,
except the opening ceremony.
- Really?
- I saw that
'cause we had like a little
viewing party at our place
'cause one of our friends
really wanted to see the opening
for some reason.
And to be fair, it's probably
like the most interesting part
of the Olympics, honestly.
- Oh, I don't know about that.
- I don't know about that.
- I mean,
if you're not into sport, right?
- I feel like you don't
even need to be into sport
to be into the Olympics.
- Oh, no, I like sport.
- There's so many good
storylines, you know?
It's a story.
- I mean, true,
but I think for the majority of people
who aren't into sport and
don't care about the Olympics,
the opening and ending ceremony
are probably like the
two biggest highlights
of just seeing, you know?
- I guess.
I don't really care
about sports in general.
I don't know why, something
about the Olympics is fun.
It's a thing where there's
just sport that's on all day
and it's changing
constantly between events
so you don't have a chance to get bored.
Like I've been watching like, you know,
I might be watching the
cycling for too long.
I'm like, "Alright, okay."
But then next, the boxing comes on.
I say, "Ooh, ooh, okay, ooh."
(Joey laughs)
And then, you know, it
keeps changing and, okay,
now you're like, "What
the fuck's going on?"
Like what is actually-
- Right, right.
- Who is winning?
- I mean, yeah, for me, the Olympics is,
I've never been really too
interested in the Olympics.
It's probably one of my least
favorite sporting events
just because there's a bit
too much going on for me.
Like, at least-
(Joey laughs)
No, 'cause we talked about-
- Least favorite sporting event.
- Yeah, I mean, we
talked about storylines.
- What's worse than the Olympics?
- Yeah.
(Garnt sighs)
- Every other sporting event. (laughs)
- I don't know, I don't know.
- What's better than the Olympics?
Well, I like most major sporting events
when they're like a build-up-
- Yeah, true, true.
- League doesn't count.
- League does count.
- Dude, League does count.
(Joey laughs)
- League does count.
- I fucking love the League finals.
- What are you, a fucking dad?
- Yeah. (laughs)
- What is this? (laughs)
- Video games ain't sport.
- What am I listening to here?
- I love the World Cup, I love the Euros,
I love the Rugby World Cup as well.
It's just like it's, for me,
it's easier to follow along the storyline
if there's just one event
or one tournament going on.
With the Olympics, it's just
like, what stage are we at?
What sport is this?
I've never even heard of this sport.
What the fuck is handball?
(Joey laughs)
How do I get invested in handball
when I don't even know the
fucking rules of handball?"
- It's just tennis
against the wall. (laughs)
- (laughs) I totally agree with you.
And so I could have
watched it on Japanese TV.
The problem is,
is that I don't understand
fully what's being said
all the time.
And I feel like,
I realized when I'm
watching on Japanese TV,
I'm like, wow, actually
knowing who the people are
and why I should give a shit
is actually really important.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- I thought just being able to leave it on
in the background,
that'd be entertaining enough.
- That's the whole point
of commentators, right?
- Right, and I realized,
so I got my VPN on
and I watched it on the British website.
- Did you use Express VPN?
- I did use Express VPN.
(Garnt laughs)
- Hell yeah.
- And, yeah,
I was watching it with
the British commentary,
and the commentary was really good.
And I didn't realize
how much it added to it.
'cause there was some commentary
that had me, like,
actually dying, laughing.
Like I think the British rowing team
didn't win any gold medals,
and one of the commentators
just couldn't hold back.
He was so pissed off.
And he was like, "The absolute
state of British rowing.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
We invested 27 million
pounds in British rowing
and we didn't get a single gold medal."
And it's was just like live on TV,
like right after they just lost.
And it's like, he's just going in.
He's like, no chill.
- Like holy shit, man.
- It's like, I felt embarrassed.
I was like, imagine you're the rowers
that made this guy on BBC go off one,
just like go on a tirade.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- Legendary.
- It's just like all the other good sports
that I don't know anything about.
Like TaeKwonDo, I don't
know anything about.
But the commentators
help explain everything
as you're going.
And it is annoying when you're
watching it for too long,
because then they start over again
and they start explaining it again
because they assume that
people are only watching
for short amounts of time.
- Yeah, because nobody knows
what the hell the rules are
for the sport.
- Yeah, yeah, so it's great.
I mean, I was watching diving as well.
Diving is really fun to watch.
- Oh yeah, diving's super fun to watch.
- It was really far.
I was like, "Whoa, okay,
I'm really invested."
- I think that's the
only sports that I like
in the Olympics,
just the obscure ones that you
never get to see otherwise.
So it's like, with tennis and rugby,
it's like, you know, that's
playing all year round, right?
- Rugby is shit in the Olympics.
Have you seen it?
- Yeah, that's pretty bad.
- It's like five minutes
a side or something
and there's only like 10 minutes of rugby.
- Well, most major sports
that have bigger competitions
are pretty shit in the Olympics, I find.
- Absolutely.
- They send the B team.
They don't send the actual-
- Yeah, yeah.
You look at the football
or the rugby or the tennis-
- Or the baseball as well.
- Yeah.
Oh, there's baseball there?
- Yeah, there's baseball.
Yeah, there's baseball in America, yeah.
- Or like basketball as well, right?
- There's basketball.
- Yeah, like sports
that have a competition
that's just more prestigious
than the Olympics
for that specific sport,
I feel like it just takes
a bit of the wind out.
The real magic of the Olympics
is watching this small sport
that you've never heard of.
- Well, yeah, because
a lot of these sports
don't have any major leagues to push them
and give them a lot of money
and they obviously don't
tell them where they get to.
- I did see a bit of the skateboarding
'cause I was interested in that.
I think Japan got a
gold medal in it, yeah.
- Yeah, like it's all kids as well.
- Yeah.
- It's like 10-year-old kids.
I'm like, "Fuck, dude."
- God, imagine being a fucking-
(Garnt laughing)
Yeah, right.
All is I know you're 10 years old.
- I realized watching the
Olympics this year has been awful.
Like every single athlete, right?
He looks like 30.
They interview him, he's like, "21,"
and he's just won the gold medal.
I'm like, "What the fuck, man?"
This man is built like a
Greek god and he's won a medal
and he's got his shit together.
What am I doing?
- Like you've reached the point where,
you reached that point when you-
- Literally everyone in the
Olympics is younger than me.
- Yeah, no, not even the Olympics.
When you grow, when you're young,
everyone you watch on TV
is just older than you.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And it's just like
something you get used to.
Like every athlete,
every major personality
is just older than you.
And then you get to a point
where you start seeing people
that's younger than you and-
- Achieving these amazing things, right?
- Achieving these amazing
things and starting football-
- And I'm like, jeez, at 21,
I was fucking masturbating
and eating Cheetos.
(Garnt laughs)
Meanwhile, these kids just won
a fucking Olympic gold medal.
- Yeah, I was getting really pissed off
'cause every single time
they introduce someone,
they were just younger than me.
And I'm like, "What the
fuck is this?" (Joey laughs)
Where is the 30-year-old?
Get him, go and get him in.
What does he do?
- He's the veteran.
- Yeah, yeah. (laughs)
- Fuck, bro. (chuckles)
- The coach is like 27 years old.
It's just like, Jesus.
- It's just pissing me off.
I'm like, surely there
has to be someone aged 24.
- That's why I kind of almost
prefer the Winter Olympics
a lot of times.
'Cause I feel that in the Winter Olympics,
there's more of those more niche sports
that you really only get
to see in the Olympics.
Otherwise you really
have to go deep for it.
Like curling, for example, is like-
- [Connor] Now curling's hard work.
- I never thought I
would care about curling
until I watched the curling
like two Winter Olympics back.
And I'm like, "Damn, I'm wanna try this.
This looks fun as fuck,"
'cause I didn't even know the
rules to curling at first.
I was like, it's just a bunch
of people scrubbing some ice.
I was like, "Alright, cool, sick."
But then when you actually learn
the intricacies of the game,
it's just like, alright,
that's actually really cool.
- I don't understand why every country
just doesn't agree to take a
week off during the Olympics.
- What, to just sit down and watch it?
- Yeah, sit down, chill, and watch it.
Why not?
Every country you can, you know,
have a week off. (chuckles)
- Seems like the world economy
might have a different,
small issue with that.
- Yeah.
- Oh, that's alright.
That's alright.
- Oh no, oh no, yeah.
I mean it's like, once every
what, four years, right?
The Olympics?
- Yeah, take a week off.
- (chuckles) I mean, okay-
- A week off in four years.
- Do you get patriotic at
all during the Olympics?
- I listen to what the
commentators tell me to do.
(Garnt laughs)
The commentators tell me I
should care about something,
I'm like, "Alright, I'm caring."
- Do you get patriotic at
all about any sporting event?
- Oh, yeah, "League of Legends."
I want the EU boys to win.
- Oh, I mean obviously.
- Obviously, yeah.
- I want the EU boys to win.
- Anything else?
- For me, the World Cup and the Euros.
I actually stayed up to watch the Euros
and watch England get beaten this time
in the finals once again.
- Good.
- [Joey] (laughs) How was that?
- It was horrible.
I had to record "Trash
Taste" that day as well,
which is why I was-
- Yeah, you stayed up 'til like 4 a.m.
- Remember the last time
we recorded "Trash Taste"
where I was absolutely dead,
it's 'cause I was up
watching England just end.
(Joey laughs)
- Well, see, I do get
patriotic over Wales in rugby.
I want Wales to win rugby.
And then if Wales get
knocked out of something
and England is still in it,
it's like, okay, now I'm
rooting for England to lose.
You'd think most people would be like-
- They be like, "Oh, I'm
rooting for England now."
- But it's not England.
- No, no, no.
It's like, I can't let England win now
because they never...
The problem is with English people
is that they're the worst when they win
at the sport they like.
- Right.
- Every time they win,
it's like every single country hates them,
'cause they somehow are the
worst country at winning.
- Yeah, they're like bad losers.
Or bad winners.
- Well, it's just like
every single country
hates having their fans in
their country, the English fans,
'cause they're the worst.
- Yeah.
- It's terrible.
- Like people will think,
because you're Welsh,
part of Great Britain,
then if Welsh aren't in it,
you're gonna root for England, right?
- No, no, no, no. (chuckles)
- And it's the complete fucking opposite.
(chuckles) Except if it's
the other way around.
Like I remember when Andy
Murray won Wimbledon.
It was Britain's first win in Wimbledon
for God knows how many years.
It was fucking decades, right?
And it was the only
time where a British...
Like English people are happy
to cheer for Scottish people,
'cause Andy Murray's Scottish, I believe,
but they aren't happy to
share the other way around.
Everyone hates English people, right?
(Joey laughs)
- Yeah, that's true.
- (laughs) And normally,
English people won't cheer
for Scottish people or Welsh people,
but once it's Great
Britain, everything's fine.
- Yeah.
- Everyone's buddy-buddy.
- Everyone's buddy-buddy again.
(Joey laughs)
It's team GB now.
- Which is really fucking confusing
'cause depending on the sport,
it's totally up to the sport
whether or not it's a Welsh,
Scottish, and English team,
or if it's a British team or some,
I think there's one or two sports
where Wales and England are
combined, but Scotland isn't.
So it's really confusing.
- That whole system
of Wales, Scotland,
it's just so confusing to
someone outside of that country.
Like I've had it explained to
me about three or four times,
I believe by YouTube,
and I still don't understand what it is.
(Garnt laughs)
- It's not that complicated.
- I'm like, so what's considered UK,
what's Great Britain,
what's the Commonwealth,
what's all of this shit?
Like it's just really confusing to me.
- I mean, do we wanna get...
Search for the video on it.
(Garnt laughs)
I could try to explain it, but-
- Yeah, 'cause there's
plenty of videos on it.
We're not gonna explain it, but-
- Yeah.
- But you should learn the Wales exists.
- See, but at least, you know,
in the case with Wales and England, right?
Like at least you got, you know,
I feel a lot of the same sports
you guys are either good
at or bad at, right?
So like say, for example,
in the rugby, right,
Wales and England, pretty good.
- Yeah.
- They're not like top-top,
but they usually stay
up near the top, right?
So at least you have that choice.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- I don't have that choice
with my two countries
because the sports that
Australia is good at,
Japan sucks at.
And sports that Japan is
good at, Australia sucks at.
So in the soccer, right,
Japan's pretty good.
Australia is shit in the cricket.
Japan don't even play cricket.
And the rugby is probably
like the only thing,
because, you know, I think
last Rugby World Cup,
Japan came eighth, I think?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Top eight or something.
- It was hosted in Japan,
so they were the host country.
- Which is hype as fuck, right?
Because Japan is never that good.
That was the only time where I was like,
"Alright, Japan, you did good,
but I'm gonna have to go back
to Australia after that."
- Is Australia good at rugby?
- Yeah, Australia's really good.
And they're in top four.
- Yeah, I don't watch sports often,
mainly because of, you know,
since we live in this time zone,
when the fuck is this shit happening?
The reason why it's so easy for me
to keep along with the Olympics
is 'cause it's just all day.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's great.
I wake up, it's on. I go to bed, it's on.
It's perfect.
- I mean, that's kind of what I liked
about big sporting competitions, you know.
Any age I was where you turn on the TV
and it's just sports
playing, and it's just fun.
And it's fun to watch something
where every match matters to somebody.
I just wish I knew more
about who was competing
in the Olympics.
- Yeah,
but there's no way you can though.
- Yeah, there's no way you can.
- Like there's so much information.
And then, you know, I was getting confused
'cause even in some of the sports,
like TaeKwonDo or some
of the martial arts,
there's weight divisions.
And there's so many weight divisions,
there's so many competitors
in the weight divisions,
and there might be multiple
ones from your country
in the one weight division.
So it's really hard to
be like, "Alright, wait,
who am I rooting for?"
What the fuck is going on?
- I just see the flag
and I'm like, "Oh, I recognize that one.
Go, that one." (laughs)
(Garnt laughs)
- That's basically what
it boils down to, right?
It's just like, "I like that country.
Let's see that country do well."
- Yeah, it's like, "Ooh,
I've never heard of Lichtenstein before.
I think they're good at this sport.
Go them."
- Are they competing in the Olympics?
- I don't even know.
Dude, okay, watching the opening ceremony,
and you know how they have to
go through all the countries?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- There was like over a hundred countries
that were competing this year.
But it was funny because they were going
not in alphabetical order,
they were going in
Japanese hiragana order,
which is completely different.
- Oh.
I was wondering what kind
of order they were going in
because it just seemed
like the most weird order
that had ever been done.
- Yeah, that's why there
were like, you know,
some countries starting with C
that came after countries starting with K,
because in Japanese alphabet,
it's in the same order.
So I remember my sister in
Australia was texting me
'cause she was watching it as well,
and she was like, "Oh, it's really funny
'cause these Australian commentators
have been explaining
for the past 10 minutes
why these countries are
coming out in this order."
(Connor laughs)
They literally have to explain
the Japanese writing system
to an Australian fucking audience.
So they're like, "Okay, so hear me out.
This is how it works and this
is why it's the weird order."
But I heard,
dude, there was so many countries in there
where I was like, yeah, that
sounds like a made up word,
like that's not a real country.
- Well, some of them, if I'm correct,
aren't even countries.
Like, I think like-
- Some of them are micronations.
- Yeah, some of them are territories
or territories of other countries.
Like there's the Cayman islands as well,
it's listed as its own country?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- I was like, "I don't think that is."
Dude, I saw some drama happen live
while I was watching boxing.
There was like a British
guy versus a French guy.
- I think that's drama already.
- Yeah, that's drama
already, which is that-
- [Joey] (laughs) Yeah.
- Let's go back to history, yeah.
- It's hotter if you got
drama over here. (laughs)
(everyone laughs)
- Napoleon just makes a
fucking, like, expose video
or whatever. (laughs)
- Yeah, it was literally like that.
And they were boxing, right?
And so obviously when you're boxing,
sometimes they do the hugging thing.
And it's like, okay, cool.
So when they were doing the hugging thing,
I think the French guy
was like, headbutting the British guy.
- Oh, shit.
- Yeah.
- And he made him bleed.
And the ref was like,
"Hey, don't do that again."
He did it again.
And then he just immediately
disqualified him.
- Right, right, right.
- The guy.
- The French guy?
- Yeah.
- And he had a fucking mentdown,
like a mental breakdown,
and started like shouting and stuff,
going up to all the cameras,
being like, "No, I won, no,
I won," into the cameras.
- Wow.
- And they were announcing it.
And he was like, "No, stop announcing it.
Stop announcing it."
- Stop the count.
(Garnt laughs)
- Yeah, yeah,
he was doing like,
"Stop, this is bullshit.
There's no way."
And he was like throwing a massive fit.
It was so crazy.
- Jesus Christ.
How did I not see that?
- I don't know.
When it was happening,
I was like, "Oh, shit,
am I watching drama live?
Yo, sick."
(Garnt laughs)
I did what any good person watching drama-
- (indistinct) use to watch "World Star."
- Yeah, I was watching-
- He watched a highly
televised "World Star."
- It was great.
The lively pop-pop thing
start popping up, like midway.
It was great.
(Joey laughs)
I immediately went to Twitter,
as any good person would
when featuring drama.
I was like, "Oh, this is great."
So I went to Twitter, I watched it,
and I was watching everyone else
talk about the drama I was watching.
It was great.
- Oh, that's weird
because I've seen so many clips
of the Olympics on Twitter.
- There's a lot more drama in
the Olympics that happened.
- I think I've watched
more Olympics on Twitter
than I have on television.
- Yeah.
- The other clips I saw of the Olympics
was that they were playing
a lot of anime music.
- Yeah, a lot of people are
doing anime stuff, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like so when you come out in boxing,
you're allowed to play your own music.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And some of them, one of
them had "Demon Slayer,"
one of the Japanese guys.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I saw that.
- I saw there was a
Greek person who did a-
- The "One Piece" thing.
- He did "Gear 2" and "One Piece."
And won the fucking gold medal as well.
(Connor laughs)
- (laughs) What a bad ass.
- And I think he set a record as well.
So I'm just like, yo, "One Piece" stands,
"One Piece" stands,
like fucking stand up, man.
- Yeah, I think one of
the volleyball matches
with the Japanese team,
they were playing the
"Haiku" theme as well.
- Oh my god. (laughs)
- Like during the interval and stuff.
And I'm like, that's so cool.
- Of course they were.
- But, yeah,
the only cool part about
the opening ceremony
was the fact that, from what I saw,
'cause admittedly,
compared to some of the
other opening ceremonies
that I've seen-
- It was a very artistic one, I'd say.
- Yeah, it was-
- You know what that means.
- Artistic.
- It's very bare bones.
- It was bare bones.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like the references I think
that people were looking for
were not in the opening,
so I think a lot of people
are hoping that it comes out
in the ending ceremony.
But I think the only cool thing was that,
during the time when all the
countries were coming out,
'cause that's like an
hour and a half segment
of all the countries coming out,
they were playing just
basically the entire discography
of Square Enix games.
(Garnt laughs)
Like literally every Square
Enix game you could think of,
they were playing the music of.
So they literally opened with
the "Dragon Quest" theme,
and they were playing "Final
Fantasy" and "Chrono Trigger."
They played the fucking
"NieR:Automata" song.
- Yeah, I heard the
"NieR" song. (chuckles)
- But not just any "NieR:Automata" song,
literally the most darkest
depressing "NieR:Automata" song
that plays in a really
sad scene in the game.
- Oh my god.
- And, man, it was like melted.
It's just like, (laughs)
(Connor and Garnt laughs)
fucking like, (wailing),
this fucking sad "NieR:Automata" music.
(laughs) It was really weird.
But I'm just thinking like,
because, you know, I think the
biggest question everyone had
who watched the opening is like,
"Where's all the Nintendo shit?"
- Yeah, that's what I was-
- Where's Pokemon?
Where's Mario?
Where's all that stuff that they promised
at the last thing.
- It's kind of odd,
'cause normally Japan
has been quite patriotic
with all of its,
especially Pokemon.
- Right.
- Japan is not as...
Ah, what's the word?
Japan has not been
scared to embrace Pokemon
as a national symbol.
- And, you know,
considering the fact that,
at the end of the last Olympics, you know-
- We had the Mario thing.
- Yeah,
like our prime minister came out of a pipe
dressed up like Mario, right?
- Yeah, well, it could be a thing
of Nintendo didn't wanna do it.
Or it could have been a thing of-
- Or I think what a lot
of people are waiting for
is because they were like, "Square Enix,
we'll let you take the opening."
But Nintendo is the end, bro.
- I don't know-
- I think that's what people are hoping.
- By the time this has come out,
we'll know the answer.
- Yeah, I guess so.
But as of right now,
that's what I think all
the theories are, but.
- Yeah, I mean like,
do you think the opening
was purposefully done
the way it is,
or is it just because
of the world situation
that they couldn't make it bigger?
'Cause that's what I assumed.
- (inhales) I feel...
I think it's the latter.
- Did you go back and watch
other opening ceremonies?
- I did.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I watched the one at
the Beijing Olympics.
Like that one was insane,
compared to Japanese.
I mean, the Japanese one was
good, don't get me wrong,
but I definitely did feel that,
I think the world situation
really did screw it over
in a lot of ways, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, 100%.
- 'Cause I was like,
I like the idea that they were going for,
but I feel it was a little underperformed.
- Just like, where's the budget? (laughs)
- Yeah, right?
It really did feel that way.
- The British one had the
fucking Queen skydiving.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- I'm like, how much
did that cost? (laughs)
Yeah, that Daniel Craig be James Bond.
There's no way he did that
for less than $50 million.
- Exactly.
- No.
- He literally hates James Bond,
as we've established.
(Garnt laughing)
Why would he wanna do that?
- Exactly, right?
- For queen and country,
obviously. (laughs)
- Bullshit, bullshit.
- So that's what I was-
- Only if I get to wear
my gloves. (laughs)
(everyone laughing)
- So that's why I was hoping
that they would have at least,
you know, some more
notable, big, big people
coming out in the opening, right?
'Cause like that's, you know,
the way to open for your country
and be braggadocious about
your country for once.
But I feel they're like-
- Yeah, it's the one time
you can actually brag
about what's going on.
- Yeah, right?
And people are waiting for you to brag.
But I feel like the references
that they did throw in
were super fucking subtle
and kind of offhand, almost?
- Yeah, what was that
guy that was tap dancing?
I didn't get that.
- Okay, yeah.
He was literally,
I think it was he's the
greatest tap dancer in Japan.
- Right, so explain, what was going on?
I watched it, I don't remember this.
- So there was this tap...
So what they did instead was,
instead of bringing out
these notable names,
they brought out Japan's best blank.
So they had Japan's best tap
dancer and he was performing
and then they had Japan's best, like,
jazz pianist.
- I do remember this.
- Yeah.
- I do remember this
and I think I was like,
"Why are they bringing
in tap dancers in Japan."
Isn't that not a Japanese thing?
- Yeah, also during a really
traditional wood scene as well,
and I'm like, "It's like
400 years difference
between tap dancing and (indistinct).
- Yeah, when I think Japan,
I don't think tap dancing, no.
- No, not at all. (laughs)
- I don't think tap
dancing and jazz piano.
That's why I don't get it.
- Yeah.
- It was just so surreal
seeing a tap dancer
dancing on a stage with nothing on it
to a crowd of zero people
in a stadium that's
meant for 30,000 people.
- Yeah.
- Oh, it's so depressing
seeing all the stadiums empty.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I actually read that,
the guy who designed the actual stadium,
to make, you know,
because obviously they couldn't
put people into the stadium.
So what they did was he
purposely designed the seats
and arranged the colors
to make it look like
there were people sitting
from a distance.
- What, how can you do that?
- There did not look like
there were people sitting
in the distance at all.
- [Joey] You decide if that
actually worked, but (laughs).
- I can say I tried to make
my fart smell like watermelon,
doesn't mean it fucking
worked, you know what I mean?
- (laughs) But I ate a
shitload of watermelons.
- What do you mean, you tried?
No you fucking didn't.
- Yeah,
that was the intent, I think.
- Yeah. (chuckles)
- But, yeah, obviously,
you know, to varying degrees of success.
- Yeah, I mean, I think a
lot of it was unfortunate
because I think another
thing about the tap dancing
is that it's 'cause of
the stadium was so big
and I don't think the microphones
were sensitive enough.
I could hardly fucking hear it.
(Joey laughs)
At that point,
it was just like fucking
stepping with attitude.
That's kind of what it felt like.
- The commentators, I was
watching it on Japanese TV,
they were explaining what was going on
more than they were
letting the audio play.
- Yeah.
- (giggles) Yeah.
- So how good of an
opening ceremony is that
if I need, I actually need,
a narrator telling me what's happening?
- Like, legit, some of the stuff
was so avant-garde-
- Yeah, it was crazy.
- But like 60% of the commentators
were doing the fucking audio commentary.
- Yeah, they were describing
exactly what was going on.
I was like, "What is this?"
- Yeah, so this represents
blah, blah, blah.
And I'm like, "Just let me watch it.
Shut up, just me watch it."
- It's not very good if I
can't discern what's going on.
- Right?
Exactly.
- Yeah, I was watching it
through the British commentary
and there was not too much commentary
'cause I think they were
just as confused as I.
- (laughs) They're
like, "What's going on?"
- Also, it's not a good opening ceremony
if you fucking talk over all of it.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I don't go watch "Of Mice and Men"
and have someone narrate in my ear
why Lenny is doing all this shit.
You know what I mean, right?
I don't need this shit.
Let it speak for itself.
It's, oh my god.
- I think the speech afterwards
of the Olympic Committee
actually went on for longer
than the performance did.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, true.
I zoned out when it happened.
- Yeah.
- So, yeah, I don't know,
maybe that was because
of a budget problem,
maybe it was because
of the world situation,
but I mean, I think a lot more people...
I think the only good
thing that came out of it
was probably Square
Enix's stocks went boom
because of the amount of music
they used at the beginning.
- I wanna know how
Square Enix was basically
just got to take over
the opening ceremony.
- Yeah.
- I have no idea.
- 'Cause there's so many other Japanese-
- Slipped someone a tenner, man.
- (laughs) Yeah.
- Yeah, honestly.
But they literally like, you know,
had the actual spotlight at that point.
I remember as well,
like it wasn't just Square Enix music.
They literally played a song
from fucking "Sonic Adventure 2."
- Are you serious?
- Yeah. One of the songs
that played in the set,
because the set piece
was leaked on Twitter
before the actual
beginning of that segment,
and in the list there
was a fucking Sonic song.
♪ Rolling around at the speed of sound ♪
- (laughs) It wasn't that one.
(Garnt laughs)
- I think if someone played it,
I would've actually lost my mind. (laughs)
- I would've given it a standing ovation.
I would've been like, "They did it.
They fucking did it."
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Yeah, best opening
ceremony of all time, woo!
- But, yeah, they legit...
I don't think it was "Sonic Adventure 2,"
but it was one of the Sonic games.
But they legitimately played a Sonic song
and I was just like-
- I mean, Sonic's pretty fucking iconic.
- I mean, hey, man,
they did it, I guess. (chuckles)
- But how did Sega get in,
and then Nintendo just didn't then?
- And I think that's why,
like that's where the confusion arose
of like, okay, so obviously
more people know...
When you think of Japan from
like a foreigner's perspective,
you think Pokemon and Mario.
- Yeah.
- Like, you don't think of
"Final Fantasy" and Sonic.
- Would you say Sonic's more
famous than "Final Fantasy"?
It is, right?
- Sonic?
- Yeah.
- Probably.
- Probably, yeah.
- Isn't that weird?
'Cause he's only had
like, three good games.
- (laughs) Yeah.
- He's literally just like,
he's cashing in on the brand-
- You mean on the first three?
- Yeah, he's literally cashing
in on the brand recognition.
- Sonic is one of those-
- Yo, "Sonic Riders" though.
- Okay.
Okay, "Sonic Riders" is good.
(Joey laughing)
I recognize that it is not
the best game. (chuckles)
"Sonic Riders," "Battle
Adventure 2" is good and "Mania."
- "Sonic Heroes" was weirdly good too.
- But isn't it strange, though,
how Sonic hasn't had the
biggest smash hit games,
yet he's still the one of the most
recognizable game figures?
- That's the thing.
Sonic is not purely surviving
off of character design.
- Brand recognition, bro.
It's branding.
- I mean, he's just an icon.
- His character design
is fucking brilliant.
It's brilliant.
- Porn.
It's gotta be all porn.
I'm convinced it's all porn.
- Yeah, that too.
- Go on, sorry.
(Garnt chuckles)
- It's just a cult following, right?
- [Connor] Yeah, true.
- You know, after "Sonic 3," right,
we haven't had a single good Sonic game.
- Oh, "Sonic Mania."
- "Mania."
- Oh, I mean, yeah.
- But, I mean, it's kind of a remake of-
- I mean, that's up for debate, right?
- I mean, it's all been 2D Sonics.
There hasn't been a good 3D Sonic.
- Yeah, all the 2D Sonics were fantastic.
- Except for, you know, "Riders."
- All the 3D Sonics except for
"Riders" was absolute trash.
And yet they can somehow pump out
all these shit Sonic games
and people are still just like,
"I mean, the next one might be better."
- Did you play "Mario and
Sonic at the Olympic Games"?
- No, I haven't.
- I fucking loved that game.
- Oh, I remember that, yeah.
- Is that a good game?
- Dude, you're like-
- I've always wanted to play that game.
- On the the 2008 Beijing Olympics one,
you couldn't get a copy of that in the UK.
- [Joey] Really?
- It was sold out everywhere.
- I'm surprised they
didn't do a re-release
for this Olympics.
- I think they did last year.
- They did last year.
- Oh, okay, okay.
- Yeah, they did last year.
- Yeah.
- This episode is sponsored by Apari.
- [Joey] Apari is an
artist-owned apparel brand
focused on delivering clothes
with fun color concepts
and high quality fabric.
The brand features original
art inspired by retro motifs
and Japanese animation.
- Joey, is that some
drip you got on there?
- It sure is, Garnt.
- Ooh.
- I'm wearing a nice
summer shirt from Apari
with, er, what is this?
Like onion pigs or something?
I don't know, it's cute
and it's aesthetic.
- Damn, is that quality
fabric right there?
- It sure is.
It's very breathable.
- Is it also artist-owned
and original art?
And it's got a fun color
concept, dare I say.
- Oh, and how breezy is that shirt, man?
- It is super breezy.
And if you look at these photos of me
modeling in the clothes,
you know how much drip
you can get out of Apari.
- Damn, did you know there's new items
for part two of the
summer/spring collection?
(Joey gasps)
And a restock of part one
is releasing today at 8:00 p.m. EST?
- Damn.
- Oh my God.
And if you missed your
chance the first time,
this is your second opportunity
to snag something from the new collection.
(Joey gasps)
- Oh my god,
and the items are limited and going fast.
(Connor screams)
- And don't forget about the Ox T-shirt.
It's got pigment, dyed,
and a vintage wash.
It should feel like a shirt you've washed
and worn for years.
- But don't also forget
about the Ox sweater as well.
- Ooh.
- And that the woven
graphic of the sweater
just looks aesthetic as hell.
- Ooh.
- Yeah, it does.
- So don't miss out on new
collections or restocks
by following their Instagram @arariart
or by checking out their mailing list
by going to apari.com.
Links in the description below.
- Back to the episode.
One thing that I noticed
that I saw a lot of
athletes complaining about
was how bad the temperature is here.
- Oh yeah.
- Like how bad the heat is.
- It's absolutely brutal here right now.
- These poor people doing
like triathlons and stuff,
and cross-country cycling.
It looks great on TV. You
can't even tell it looks hot.
Like it just looks like,
"Oh, good weather, nice."
It's disgusting here.
- Yeah, I mean, we talked
about this last week,
but the summer here is fucking disgusting.
- It's insane.
And just these poor athletes
who have to do hour long
events in this heat.
- Alright, right now where
we are, it is 34 degrees,
but because of the humidity,
it feels like 41 degrees.
- It's insane.
- Fuck that.
- It do be like that.
- Like, even just walking
from the train station to the office,
it's a nice, brisk five, 10 minute walk,
I'm fucking dying by the time I get here.
- I don't care where you live
or what fucking temperature it is,
no one should be doing
sports in 41 fucking celsius.
- Yeah. (laughs)
No one should be doing a
triathlon in 40 degrees celsius.
- No.
- I don't care
if you were raising the
magma crust of this earth.
I know there's gonna be one comment
who's like, "Oh, it's 50, right?"
Fuck off.
- Yeah, you're not doing a
triathlon in 50 degrees, are you?
- Oh my god.
- Yeah, I'm wondering, like,
how the fuck are they doing this?
Or how is anyone meant to
compete in this weather?
- I wonder why.
I'm pretty sure I read something.
I could be totally, totally
wrong with this one,
that apparently they did try and ask,
Japan did try and tell them
like, "Hey, we should do it
in September or something."
But the IOC was like, "Nope,
we're doing it in July."
(Garnt laughs)
- And of all the sports that
are perfect for this heat,
AKA, the swimming, is done indoors,
so it's like not a point.
(Garnt and Connor laughs)
At least do that outside, you know?
It will feel good for the athletes.
- Yeah, Jesus.
I feel bad now.
I didn't even think about that.
They must be absolutely
dying out there in the heat.
- Dude, it's brutal.
- Ripperonies.
- Yeah.
- But like, I mean,
how much is left of the
Olympics now that we are-
- I don't know, not many Olympic
days left at where we are.
- 'Cause it's only like a
two week event, isn't it?
- Yeah, we're on day-
- Is it that short?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Shit.
- We're like day 12 or something.
- I thought it was like a
couple of months or something.
- No, it has to be done.
I think one of the rules in the contract
with the Olympics Committee
to the local government
is that it needs to be
done within like two weeks.
- [Joey] Oh, wow.
- And no longer, no less.
Like it has to-
- Why does it feel like every Olympics,
it lasts so much longer than that?
Is it because it's just so stacked?
- Because, like, the
hype for it is built up
more than any E3 event tenfold.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And "No Man's Sky" wishes
that it had this much hype.
(Joey laughs)
We've lived in Japan for
like two years now, right?
And since day one, since we've been here,
you've been seeing Tokyo 2020 stuff
everywhere.
- That's true.
- Like it's insane.
Like everything is Tokyo 2020.
Like you go and get a chocolate bar,
Tokyo 2020 is on it for some reason.
I don't know why.
Why is this on there?
- We did actually buy some
Tokyo 2020 merchandise
just because, like...
Well, think about it, right?
Like, it's one of the few,
if not the only Olympics,
that has ever been in this
like weird world situation
where it's been delayed by a year, right?
And it's so telling of its...
I think Aki bought a Tokyo 2020 face mask.
That, 50 years from now, is
gonna be a great story to tell
because it's like, you know-
- Should've done that myself.
- Just to say that like, yeah,
we'd lived through a time
when there was such like
an insane world pandemic
that we literally had to A,
cancel the Olympics for a year,
but B, everyone had to fucking
wear this for two years.
- I mean, it's weird, right,
because I feel like this
Olympics, the hype just...
Like you talked about the hype,
but I just haven't felt the hype at all
behind this year's Olympics.
- Well, because I think the
last year, before COVID hit,
the hype was definitely building up.
- Oh yeah, it was definitely there.
- But I think the moment COVID hit
and it got pushed back
a year is when I think-
- And then the hype for COVID happened.
- Yeah, and then I think
pretty much the general people
just turned against the Olympics
and they were like, "We
don't want it anymore."
- Yeah.
- Even though Japan is
doing exceedingly well
this Olympics as well.
- Are they?
- Oh yeah. They've won a
lot of gold medals already.
- Oh yeah, they're third
right now, I think, actually.
- Oh, shit. okay.
- No, they're doing very well.
- Yeah, see, I just haven't
been following along
as much as I used to just
because, I don't know,
like I said, the hype
just doesn't feel there
obviously in Japan,
'cause Japanese people
don't want it to happen
for obvious reasons.
But also internationally,
it just feels like there's
been a lot less talk
about it as well.
You see the odd article,
we see the odd clip.
- Yeah, it's been a rough year, I think.
I think also political
situations are getting rough
and you're seeing it in
the Olympics as well.
- Yeah, it's been in a lot of talks,
just not for the right
reasons a lot of the time.
- Yeah, it just feels like, you know,
at least like Olympics pre-,
I don't know, like 2012, 2016,
maybe not 2016, I don't know,
it didn't feel as fucked
politically as well.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- There's a lot of politics in
it now. And there always was,
maybe I was just younger
and I didn't realize,
but it just, yeah, it feels very tense.
- Yeah.
Yeah, I mean, the world is
in a tense state right now,
just in general,
so it definitely just doesn't help.
Everyone's just on edge now.
- Yeah, I mean, like it's, you know,
everyone loves the idea of the Olympics,
just like every nation gets together
and we just play a bunch
of sports and have-
- And put our differences aside.
- Put our differences-
- Play some ball.
- Yeah, put our differences
aside and play some games.
- Friendly competition.
- Friendly competitions.
And you know, in any other Olympics,
I feel like that is the case.
In this Olympics, it just
feels like nobody really,
everyone's just forgotten to care
because everyone's just like,
"Can we just have the world open back up?"
- Yeah.
- I just wanna go to Denny's.
- I see the empty seats there.
It's reminding me that it's
still a depressing situation
in the world.
Well, most of the world, at least.
So I don't know, it's been difficult.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Definitely, definitely.
Just want it to be open.
- Who has been winning the Olympics?
I have not been keeping up with it at all.
- Ah, China's winning
right now, if I saw before.
- It's always China and
USA at the top, right?
- Yeah.
- And then Japan.
And then I think Australia and Britain
are neck and neck for fourth,
but it's hard to tell what's gonna happen.
But, I mean, China or
USA normally always win.
- Yeah, they're usually the top two.
- And then that's like the
Cold War-esque thing for them
where it matters who
wins that politically.
- That's the friendly
competition, unless...
(Garnt laughs)
- Friendly? (laughs)
- [Crew Member] Know ranking?
- Yeah, what's the ranking now?
- Yeah, yeah, what's the ranking?
- [Crew Member] So People's
Republic of China, 32 golds.
- Uh-huh.
- Okay.
- [Crew Member] United
States of America, 25 golds.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- [Crew Member] Japan,
number three, with 20 golds
- Nice.
- Oh, wow.
- [Crew Member] Australia, 15 golds.
- [Joey] Let's go.
- [Crew Member] ROC, Republic of...
- Oh, that's Russia.
- That's Russia.
- [Crew Member] ROC is
fifth, Great Britain sixth.
- Oh, okay.
- Okay.
- Oh, shit, I was wrong.
- Guess Britain isn't doing
too well this Olympics, are we?
- Like that commentator said, man,
absolute embarrassment for British rowing.
(Garnt laughs)
- The absolute stink. (laughs)
- The absolute stink British rowing.
Well, it was one of the events
that Britain used to win
at least somewhat consistently.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- I mean, I feel like
it's somewhat big part
of British culture.
- Yeah, what have we got?
- One of the only sports
that's like one of the things
where we actually have a big deal about.
- Yeah, it's like rowing
and cycling, right,
that we usually just like-
- Cycling, we normally have
a really good turn out.
British people love fucking
cycling for some reason.
- Yeah.
- Really?
- 'Cause we invented football
and then everyone, every nation
just beat us at football.
So we're like, okay, we've
gotta find another sport.
- Did we invent cricket?
I don't know if we invented cricket.
- I'm pretty sure we invented cricket.
- I think you guys invented cricket.
- And rugby.
- Yeah.
- And then Australia was like.
(everyone laughing)
- I saw that meme where it was like,
Britain invents a sport,
gives it to other country,
they become better at it.
And then America is like,
invent a sport,
no one plays it,
become number one.
(everyone laughing)
- It's true.
- It's crazy. (laughs)
American football, lmao.
- Dude, have you watched the
American football before?
Are you into it at all?
- No, but I love watching the drama
around American football.
It's very good.
- What drama?
- You know, there's always
documentaries about it.
I've watched, what is it,
"Last Chance U," I think
it's called, on Netflix.
It's about college football
and they get, like,
they follow a team and try
and get to win the league,
and it's just very funny.
- Oh.
- And it's just insane,
the lengths they go to get
these kids to play football.
- Based on a true story?
- Oh, no, so literally
just following them.
- Oh, it's like a documentary.
Right, right, right.
- Yeah, they just literally
pick a school and follow them.
- Okay, yeah, yeah.
- And, yeah, that's
pretty good, on Netflix.
I watched the one thing
about that NFL player
who killed a guy.
- What?
- It was like an NFL player
who killed someone and, yeah.
These NFL players are crazy, man.
Like a lot of them are like,
they get up to very interesting
stuff in their free time.
- Like killing people. (laughs)
- Yeah, yeah. (laughs)
Also the whole thing where they
get mad concussions from it
and they all get like, brain damage.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, like I've seen
that Will Smith movie.
- Yeah, it's pretty rough, isn't it?
- Yeah.
- I mean, I watched the super...
I was about to say super
bowel, for a second. (laughs)
(everyone laughs)
- Superbowl.
- I just like super bowel, my favorite.
- The Superbowl.
- Did you feel like it's
like the most foreign thing
to a British person,
hearing the word Superbowl.
I'm like, "What is that?"
"What is it?" The whole-
- Okay, okay, so-
- Growing up, you hear
about the Superbowl.
- That's a really big bowl.
- So there's me watching the Superbowl
before I watch "Eyeshield 21."
(Joey laughs)
And there's me watching Superbowl
after I've watched "Eyeshield 21."
- See, I watched Superbowl after reading-
- They're like, "Where's
the Devil Bat Ghosts?"
- Yeah. (laughs)
- "Where's the Rodeo Drives?"
- I watched the Superbowl
after reading "Eyeshield 21,"
which is a football manga.
- Yeah.
- And I still don't know
what the fuck is going on.
- Really?
- I kind of get the rules, but I-
- Well, you get the rules
now at least, right?
- But I don't understand
how the Superbowl is formed.
How does it become?
Who gets to play in the Superbowl?
What are the rules?
- Well, you follow the
LEC and the LCS, right?
- Mm, yeah.
- It's exactly the same format.
- Oh, just playoffs?
- They literally based
League from American sports.
- Oh, why is it called the Superbowl?
What about it-
- 'Cause it's like the final, right?
I don't know why it's
called the Superbowl.
- Is there a reason?
- It's just-
- Why not "The Playoffs"?
That sounds good.
I understand the playoffs.
The playoffs makes sense.
(Garnt laughs)
- Maybe it has to do with the UN?
- No, no, no, the playoffs
lead to the Superbowl,
so the Superbowl is like
the final of the playoffs.
- Oh, so Superbowl is the
name for the final match.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- British man learns about
American football, man.
(Garnt laughs) I don't know,
this is so foreign to me.
- I only know this 'cause I follow League,
and League is based on American
football, American sports.
- I think it has to do with
the name of the actual cup you win, right?
- Do you watch American football?
Oh, yeah, wait, no, that's not a bowl.
It's like a...
I don't know what it is.
- Maybe it is, I don't know.
I mean, that's why the Ashes
are called the Ashes, right?
- No, can't figure that out.
- Dude, I know more about
the American sports system
than I do about cricket.
I like-
- So do you watch American football?
- I mean, I watch the Superbowl.
And anytime I go to America,
they're always watching
football every week,
and I pretend to care about-
- Yeah,
I watch the football in
America when it's on TV.
I don't willingly go and watch it.
But when it's on, I'm like,
okay, that's pretty cool.
- Watching normal football,
you know, you get the
ads just in the halftime.
- Yeah.
- That's when you get the ads.
There's no other ads.
The 40 minutes is straight playing.
- Yeah.
- So it was really weird and jarring
when I watched American football.
And every time there's
like an attempt, I think,
there's an ad. And I was
like, whoa, what the-
- Yeah, because there's
so many starts and stops.
- Yeah, yeah, the starts and stops,
and of course they put ads
there, but it's just so jarring.
I'm like, fucking, I don't
wanna hear about fucking Cheetos
and Bud Light, man.
I just, like, I can't do this.
- That's literally the two
forces that drive the NFL.
- It was hard to get invested
'cause every 10 seconds there'd be an ad.
And I was like, "Oh my god."
- I mean, it's just
everything is monetized
in American sports.
- Yeah, and also,
watching American TV in American hotels
is really weird as well because, you know,
we have our ads before the program starts
and in the middle of the program, right?
And when I was watching American TV,
I don't know if they changed it or what,
but I was watching it
and they let the show
play for like two minutes.
- And then they have an ad.
- Yeah.
- And I'm like, "What is this?
What is this?
Is it YouTube video?
What the fuck is this?"
- It's more consistent than a mid-roll?
- It is.
They put two mid-rolls and two end-rolls,
'cause they have the intro,
they have the clickbait intro.
- Yeah.
(Joey laughs)
- Then they have an ad,
and then the actual
intro to the show plays,
half the show plays, ad,
second half of the show plays,
and then they have an ad.
And then, you know, there's
like an end credit scene
or something like that,
or a scene that plays during the credits.
So they have an ad, and
then an end credit scene,
and then it goes on to the next show.
- Or sometimes it's even worse.
It's sometimes the end start rolling,
that minimizes into a
corner and shows an ad.
It's like another one that I've seen.
I'm like, "Am I watching an end credit
or am I watching an ad?"
- I think I was watching "South Park"
and they played legitimately
the first two minutes
of the actual episode
and then they played an ad, right?
And then they played like
20 minutes of the episode.
Nearly near the end, right
before the end, another ad.
- Yeah, right before the end, right?
- Like a minute or two
before the show finishes.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- And then before it
concludes, they play an ad.
And then they play the two
minutes of the episode,
and then they don't have
a break or anything,
they immediately start the
next episode of "South Park."
- Yeah.
- Oh, right.
- And let two minutes of that play
and then they play an ad again, right?
- Yeah.
- Right, right.
- And so it's like, I was losing my mind.
- They're all in the wrong place.
- I was actually getting so
angry watching "South Park"
because I was like,
"Why do they keep putting
the ads like this?"
It feels like I'm being bombarded.
I can't think straight.
Where is the clear act of
we put an ad in the middle
and before the show?
When did this go out the window?
- I mean, it's because viewers
are more likely to keep watching the show.
- It's fucked up, man.
It's fucked up.
- I know why it is.
I hate it.
- It's so fucked up.
- I hate it from like an
entertainment standpoint,
to be like,
just let me watch a clear
chunk of this one episode,
have a clear moment where, you know,
the episode ends and the next one begins
and that's where the ad break goes.
- Yeah, they don't give you
a chance to take a pee break
in between an episode.
- Yeah.
- It's 'cause they're like,
"Oh, you might change the channel.
So we'll just play it immediately."
So the next two minutes, now
you can go for your pee break.
- When did this change?
When was it like this?
- I think it's always
been like this in America.
- Has it really?
- Yeah.
- I have no idea.
- Fuck.
- I mean, ever since,
like the first time I went
to America, it was like this.
And I remember that was
one of the first thing
I noticed as well.
But then you look at like, how,
'cause normally when you
binge watch American TV shows,
there's a very clear cut of
where they put the ads in.
And it's just at a weird moment
compared to British TV shows,
which is just beginning,
halfway through the episode, then ending.
- Yeah, we have really strict
rules on advertising and stuff
so there's never any overlays
or anything on the program.
- Meanwhile, Japanese TV is like,
put as many ads in as you
possibly can every five minutes.
- It's so weird, the stuff
they promote in Japan.
But then you remember
it's for elderly people.
Elderly people only watch TV,
so then it all kind of makes sense.
Like they advertise futons all the time.
- Futons?
- Yeah.
- The hell kind of shows
are you watching? (laughs)
- Just normal, like NHK,
they'll just cut to a futon.
And there's so, so many telecall shows.
- Oh, telemarketing shows, yeah.
- Telemarketing shows, so many.
- What's telemarketing shows?
- There's like three or four channels
of telemarketing.
- Where they like,
basically just play ads
and it's literally just,
it's literally whole networks.
And they're not like way back,
they're like four or five on the remote.
And it's just like a whole
network dedicated to ads,
and they show you the product,
then you can call up and buy it.
- Yeah, it's literally like-
- Oh, it's like QVC or one of those-
- But imagine if QVC
was like, number five.
(Garnt laughs) QVC is number
20 in the UK or something.
- Yeah.
- Right, right.
- It's like way, way
down, as it should be.
It's just ads, no one wants to watch that.
- Just think of, like,
if the ShamWow guy was
just constantly promoting
different types of ShamWow 24 hours a day.
- So it's just an infomercial channel?
- Literally an infomercial channel.
- There's like, three of them,
and they're the first
10 shows or something.
I could be chatting out my ass, but-
- Honestly, like-
- There's a lot of them.
- I mean, I can kind of see why
there would be so many
infomercial kind of channels.
'Cause, I don't know, like-
- Old people don't use the
internet to buy things.
- Yeah, they don't know what Amazon is.
- Okay, so when you're a kid, right,
and you had a sick day, okay,
so I remember as a kid, you know,
you'd enjoy the fact
that you had a sick day
'cause, great, I don't
have to go to school,
but what do you do?
So back when I was a kid,
I did had nothing but just
had television, right?
- Yeah.
- So you had the morning TV shows,
you had CBBC, when I was growing up,
and then it was like between 8:00 a.m.
to I think around 10:00 a.m.,
which was just like, "Brilliant, I'm sick,
I get to watch TV programs
for as long as I stay home."
And then 10:00 a.m. hits
and then there is just
nothing to fucking watch.
Like there is nothing on TV at all.
And I remember I'd just be like, "Great,
I guess I'll just
fucking put on QVC then,"
'cause there's literally
nothing else interesting on.
- What?
There was "Jeremy Kyle" back then.
You could watch-
- I didn't get "Jeremy Kyle"
as a fucking seven-year-old.
- I did when I was a
10-year-old. I loved it.
I loved the shouting and stuff,
and all the people jumping around.
I loved it.
- Yeah, well, I think it's
because during weekdays,
you know, in the middle of the day,
the only people who are watching TV
is anywhere below eight and
anywhere above 80, right?
'Cause everyone else is at work or school.
- Yeah, 'cause if I can't
watch something on the TV,
at least like watch some shiny products.
That's how my brain's wired, right?
- You're like, "Oh, if
I can't watch something,
I might as well be advertised to."
- Yeah. (laugh)
(Garnt laughs)
- I may as well.
Mum, we have to get this diamond necklace.
The guy on the TV said we get three
if we purchase one. (chuckles)
(Garnt chuckling)
- God.
'Cause I remember seeing
all those infomercial stuff
during childhood, and even
10-year-old me was watching
and I was like, "Who
the fuck's buying this?"
Like, "Who is buying this shit?"
- My permanent favorite thing of those
is that like, you know,
so they're advertising the product,
it looks fantastic, you know,
you're like, "Wow, this looks great.
It's a mop that cleans my
floor and it cleans itself.
This is fantastic."
And you're like, "Great,
I'm already sold."
And you get to the end and it's like,
"But if you act now,
you can get not one, not
two, but three extra mops."
And you're like, "Whoa,
this is just too many mops.
I only wanted the one."
Now you have three.
"And if you buy now on this exact moment,
you get two extra days free shipping."
It's like, alright,
this is just ridiculous.
They keep throwing things in like,
"And if you pay by card,
we'll come to your house
and install it for you."
It's like, whoa, whoa, whoa.
And then the program will end,
and then you can tell they've done this
'cause they did it all the fucking time,
they would record an extra bit
after it clearly didn't
sell well enough, whatever,
and they would cut to another
bit and it would be like,
"But fuck that part.
If you buy now, you'll
get five instead of three,
only for today."
It's like, what is going on?
- What's going on?
- I'm losing my fucking mind.
- Yeah,
they literally just keep adding on shit,
and it's always like, it needs
to be now that you call it.
Like before the next
thing comes, you need it.
So there's people probably
just sitting there
just waiting to call, "Oh,
wait, there's another thing."
Can I call it now?
Can I call it?
- Half the time I was sold before,
and now they're just raising my concerns
'cause now this is now too much.
This is too much fodder.
- Now it's too good to be true.
- Yeah, now this is way too
many products for the price.
I was sold on the $50 pen,
and now you're telling me
you're gonna include three pens?
No way. (Joey laughs)
This is a cast iron pen.
It should not be costing $10
per pen, including shipping.
This is a joke.
- What set me off was
when they would introduce,
when they would include a product
that had nothing to do with the product
that they were advertising.
- Yeah, yeah, true.
- Or they just tacked it on for free.
Like, where did this come from?
(Joey and Connor laughs)
- You get the jewelry and they're like,
"And now we're throwing
an extra Tenga on top."
Alright, well, this is totally unrelated.
It's a bloody joke.
- All of this is worth $300,
but we're selling it for $30.
- (laughs) It's like,
is it really? Really?
- There's no way all of these
companies are making money.
- Yeah, exactly.
I'm pretty sure I saw this thing,
that you're tacking on
yesterday's infomercial,
so it clearly didn't sell well.
- They have like a golden age.
'Cause I felt like there was a time
when the products were
actually semi decent.
Like you'd go to the supermarket
and you actually see the section
of "As seen on TV" product
and some of them were
actually pretty good.
- Well, I mean,
look at how much the
fucking ShamWow sold, right?
Like that side isn't-
- I think it was just before
the internet was invented.
So now you can just
search up whatever product
you kind of need,
and if not, then Japan has
a whole store for them.
It's called fucking Daiso.
- (chuckles) Yeah.
- So you just walk into Daiso
and then you just find products
that you never knew you needed
until you walked into Daiso.
- Yeah, we need a sign now
that just says, "As seen on Daiso."
As seen at Daiso. (laughs)
(Garnt laughs)
- Wow.
- Like, Japan is just like the king
of creating these little devices
which have just exactly one use,
one very, very specific use
that you never thought about
until you see it in the store.
And just like, "Wow, I
guess I do need gloves
that can clean dishes at
the same time." (laughs)
(Joey laughs)
- There's a lot of stuff like that.
- I guess I do need slippers
that have mops on them
so that I can walk around
while mopping the house.
I guess that's a thing.
(Joey laughs)
It's only 200 yen.
Fuck it, I'll take it.
Yeah, why not?
Meanwhile, if I saw that on TV,
I'll be like, "Who the fuck buys this?
Who needs some slipper
that wipes the floor?"
- They also like, it's
like 100 yen stores,
so like less than a dollar,
it's around a dollar but just under,
and my favorite thing is
that sometimes in Daiso,
they'll have the same
product but different brands
and they're all the same price.
And I'm just like, "What is this?"
Like, if you're gonna have your
competitor right next to you
for the same price, and what
I think is the same quality,
what is the purpose of this?
Illusion of choice?
- Well, there's clearly
not much competition.
- There's obviously not a
lot of competition out there.
- Like, "Dragon's Den"
would never work for Japan
because you get the CEO of Daiso there,
and he'll just say yes to every idea.
(everyone laughs)
He'll be like, "I'll put in an offer."
- He just opens mouth, "I'm sold.
I don't even wanna hear what it is,
I'm putting it in my store."
- Give it to me. (laughs)
- Could imagine "Dragon's Den" in the UK?
They'd have 10 fucking
minutes introducing each other
before they even actually
start the fucking pitch.
And I mean, they hand out business cards.
(everyone laughing)
The person pitching would have to go
and fucking pour him water and everything,
like it's like they can't even start,
and oh my God.
(Garnt laughs)
- Jesus.
- They'd have to start with
a board meeting or something
before they even get in the room.
- Yeah, they would, they
would. Could you imagine?
I bet the people being
pitched would be like,
"No, we know exactly what's happening.
I want to see the script
of the man pitching
before he pitches it."
You know, it's like insane. (laughs)
I would love to see it actually.
- What I never understood
about those shows
is that it's just like,
it's sold as, you know,
these are very real
businesses and very real ideas
that some of them actually go
on to be successful and stuff.
But you look at some
of the people going on
and you're just like, "Okay,
I've watched 'Dragon's Den' before."
Or 'Shark Tank,' which is
the American version, right?
There's a very simple formula,
there's very specific questions
that all the dragons ask
every single fucking time,
and somehow 90% of the contestants
never know their fucking numbers.
Surely that's the first thing you do
if you figure out you're going
on "Dragon's Den," right?
You're like, "Alright,
let me just figure out my
fucking profit margins."
That's literally the
first thing you should do.
- Yeah, they're like,
"What's your gross like?"
"Uh, sorry, what?"
What is it?
(Garnt laughs)
- I'm not gross, thank you very much.
- They'll ask like, "What
is your target audience?"
or whatever, and they'd
be like, "I don't know."
- People. (laughs)
People with money.
- I saw this one clip and
it made me fucking laugh.
It was on the British one.
It was from the guy who's like
the worst, he's like so...
What is he called?
I think it was Touker?
- Touker?
- Touker, toot-toot, Touker?
- Sounds like a "Breaking Bad" character.
- Yeah, Touker, right?
He's like the guy who all
the other dragons hate
on the British one.
And it's just a great moment.
He's pitching their offer to them
and he's like, "Okay,
so I'm gonna give you
the 50,000 pounds you asked for."
- I've seen this clip.
- "For 90% of the business."
- What?
- And then the dragons were
like, "So all of the business.
So you're trying to buy the
business off of him." (laughs)
- Wait, what's the remaining 10%?
- You can't do anything with 10%. (laughs)
- (laughs) Oh, I remember.
So the person he was pitching to was like,
"So who are you giving the money to?"
And he's like, "I'm giving
the money to the business."
And he was like, "But you
own 90% of the business."
(Connor and Joey laughing)
So you're giving the money
to yourself. (laughs)
(laughing) And I'm just like-
- That was so good. (laughs)
And all the other dragons are
like, "What the fuck, bro?
What the fuck is this?"
- Ultimate money laundering.
(Garnt laughing)
- But imagine if he got to accept,
he'd be like, "Shut up, dragons, shut up.
He's gonna agree to it."
- [Joey] Oh my God.
- Like, what is this?
These are supposed to be professional...
Sometimes you see the Dragons, right?
You're like, "You're not a
fucking good businessman.
You just got really fucking
lucky with one business
and managed to convince
this TV show to let you on."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Some of them have no fucking idea
what they're doing, I swear.
They'll be like, "Yeah,
he's got a multimillion dollar business."
And then when you think about businesses,
multimillion dollar business
is actually not that difficult.
- No.
- You know, 'cause it's so stark,
the contrast between "Shark
Tank" and "Dragon's Den."
Like "Shark Tank" have Mark Cuban
and full-on fucking billionaires.
- Like, really, really,
really, really, really-
- Like, really, really-
- Successful people, yeah.
- Super, super fucking wealthy.
And then compared to
like the dragons, it's-
- Yeah, I think half the
dragons are pretty successful,
but they've had trouble
keeping the seats filled.
- Right.
- And they always bring in
people. And a lot of the time
they've had businesses that they just sold
and made like 4 million,
which is obviously a shit ton
of money, don't get me wrong,
but we're talking businesses.
You know, it's not really a good proven-
- In the business world,
4 million's not like-
- You know,
I wouldn't say it's a
hardcore proven track record
that you know how to run a business 100%.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- Alright, you might've
got lucky here and there,
you had a good idea.
It doesn't prove that you...
I don't think that's good enough
where you can go on and
start telling people
how to run their businesses.
You know what I mean?
Possibly, you know.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Nah, I get it, I get it.
- I was just kinda like,
"Alright, okay, alright."
They introduced something like,
"He made $2 million off of
his online card business."
And I'm like, "What?
what is that?"
- Never even heard of it
- That's hardly a business.
Oh, who am I kidding, I'm insulting them.
$2 million (laughs), piss off.
- Child's play.
- I don't know, I just
think when you, you know,
we're talking a lot of businesses here,
that's not that much in business terms.
- Well, yeah, in the business world,
it's not that much, yeah.
- Yeah.
- In layman's terms, it is. (laughs)
- Yeah, I think that's how the show works
is that most people
watching the show in the UK,
obviously a million pounds is-
- Yeah, like, whoa, 2 million pounds.
That's fucking insane, yeah.
- Most people can't comprehend that.
But, you know, when you work
with some businesses and stuff
and you understand the
margins they're working with,
that's not that much.
- No.
- But I guess it doesn't matter.
It's TV at the end of the day.
They're not actually trying to, like,
it's not actually trying to
give good business advice.
(Joey laughs)
It's a fucking TV show.
- Entertainment, yeah.
- No, if they did,
people would know what their net profit is
and their margins are.
- I swear some of the
British ones are staged.
- They must be. They must be.
- No way.
Some of the stuff.
'Cause there's one time they
had a pyramid scheme come on,
on the British TV show.
Like a guy that came in
who just advertised the Ponzi scheme.
- (chuckles) Did he actually?
- Yeah, and the dragons were like,
"This sounds awfully a lot
like a pyramid scheme."
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
Just type it in.
It's called "Pyramid Scheme Dragon's Den."
It will come up.
It was a good clip.
- This episode is sponsored by Bokksu.
- Hey, guys, come have
a closer look at this.
- What's up?
- Would you like some
delicious and tasty snacks
straight from Japan?
- Snacks?
- Straight from Japan?
Yes, we do.
(Joey gasps)
- Well, Bokksu's got you covered.
- Oh my god.
- Ah!
- Bokksu's the monthly snack
box subscription service
that delivers original assortments
of premium Japanese
snacks and tea pairings.
- First time Bokksu customers
will receive the "Seasons of Japan" box
so they could get a taste
of the snacks per season.
And shipping to the US is the free.
- (gasps) This month we're
celebrating the Moon festival.
(Joey gasps)
It goes by many names.
Mid-Autumn festival, Otsukimi, and Jugoya.
- Nihongo Joseph.
- All of these indicate the 15th night
of the eighth lunar moon,
the night of the Harvest Moon.
- I know that game. (laughs)
- Look at these usagi no shippo,
green tea buns.
(Joey gasps)
They make my heart go pyong, pyong.
(Joey laughs)
- I got these Setouchi lemon mochi.
Don't they look so lemony?
- Eh.
- And I'm drinking some
Hoshino hojicha latte,
which is delightful.
(Joey gasps)
- So use our code TRASHTASTE10
and the link in the description
to get 10% off your Bokksu subscription.
- Thank you to Bokksu for the
sponsor. Back to the show.
- You guys play "Pokemon Unite" yet?
- No, I haven't. (sighs)
- Why not?
- 'Cause I don't give a shit about MOBAs.
- Oh, true.
- But you do give a shit about Pokemon.
- Yeah, But there's a... I
don't know if you've heard,
but there's about a hundred
other Pokemon games out there
that I could also play. (laughs)
But, yeah, I don't know,
I saw a piece of news on Twitter.
I don't know how true this
is, but I think it was day two
or day three that "Pokemon Unite" came out
and the League players were
like, "Oh, oh, what's this?"
And then they invaded it
and now apparently it's just full of,
it's either you're versing
children who are eight years old
or you're versing League players.
And I'm like, "That sounds
like a terrible place."
- That just sounds like League 2.0.
- Yeah, so I'm like,
"I like you, Pokemon, but no thank you."
- Yeah, the games are either very fun
or not fun at all.
- Right.
- You either get stomped or you don't.
- As a gamer and a mobile player,
how do you find it?
- As a toxic gamer, how do you find it?
- Yeah, as a toxic gamer, I enjoyed it.
I didn't like the fact that
I couldn't racially slur
within 10 seconds of getting
in the game, obviously.
That was very unfortunate.
- Of course.
- There was no chat feature.
There's actually voice chat apparently.
- Is there?
- Apparently.
I don't know how.
You have to hook up the mic
through Nintendo's
bullshit way of doing it.
You plug it into your phone.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
- But I saw a voice
chat option on the game.
- Oh, yeah, no, I have done that
through "Animal Crossing" actually.
And it does not work. (laugh)
- Well, there's a chance that,
if you're a League player,
you could say something horrible
to that 10-year-old kid.
- Right.
- Nah, I'm kidding, obviously.
But I mean, yeah, it's fine, it's weird.
It's Pokemon,
but it definitely feels
like it's been developed
not by Nintendo.
Like you can-
- So has it been developed by Nintendo?
- No, it's by Tencent.
- Oh, of course, of course.
- Yeah, Tencent has, I
guess, a monopoly on MOBAs.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it's weird, man.
It's like when you haven't
seen that family member
in like 10 years
and he comes back and he's really weird,
and he's like, "Yeah,
I'm the same guy, right?"
You're like, "No.
No, what is this?
You're not the same person."
- Right, right.
- It's like, you know, you boot it up,
there's Gacha, there's loot boxes.
- Oh, that's so weird.
- You can buy gems.
It's like, oh my God, this isn't Pokemon.
What is this?
- Nintendo micro-transactioning?
- Yeah, Nintendo's been
getting real comfortable
with those micro-transactions lately.
They've been getting real
comfortable with those loot boxes.
Alright, okay.
(Joey laughs)
- Yeah, I mean, I haven't
played "Pokemon Unite,"
but I've seen clips, looked
into it, and it's so weird.
Where did this come from?
Was this announced a while ago?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause the whole idea
of a Pokemon MOBA is just
like, how did this happen?
When I think Pokemon,
I don't think "League of
Legends", "Dota," "Pokemon."
- Well, I mean, people
thought that about Pokemon
when fucking "Pokken" came out, right?
Like people were like, "Wait, what?"
- That's true.
- "Pokken's" a great game, that's true.
- Which is a great game now, right?
But I remember when it
was first announced,
people were like, "This looks horrible.
This just doesn't-"
- Really?
I thought it looked epic when it came out.
- No, I thought it looked epic.
But I saw a lot of people were
like, "That doesn't work."
- I don't know, there's
just something sad.
There's something sad
about seeing a child's game
by Nintendo like this that's
just shoved full of these
egregious micro-transactions.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, true.
- But I mean, you know, it's whatever.
You can have a differing opinion on it.
I wouldn't give a shit, I don't mind.
- So did you fall for the Gacha yet?
- Yeah, Tectone.
I played with a friend of ours
and he was like-
- Oh, Lord. (laughs)
- And he is Gacha whale,
that is pretty much his job.
- He's more like a leviathan, isn't he?
- Yeah, within five minutes,
he was like, "Spend a hundred bucks.
Just spend a hundred bucks.
Just get everything.
Just unlock everything."
And I'm like, "No, I'm not gonna do that."
And he's like, "I'll
give you a hundred bucks
to spend on it right now."
(Garnt laughing)
And I was like, "What the fuck?"
- This man, when it comes to Gacha,
this man loses all sense of money.
- He has no way of holding back,
but I respect it, you know, it's his job.
- [Joey] Oh, yeah, of course.
- But I just didn't want it
'cause I could tell that...
I ended up spending 40 bucks on it
and I was like, "I'm not
gonna play this again,
but I'm gonna do it so I can play ranked."
- Is it free to play?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- That doesn't excuse it, Garnt. (laughs)
- (laughs) No, I was just asking.
I was just asking.
You said you spent 40
bucks, which is like-
- Free to play is the
road to losing. (laughs)
- There is items you can buy
that'll boost your stats
in-game so you can actually-
- Oh.
- It's kind of like the way-
- Is it pay-to-win?
- Mm.
(Joey laughs)
The way it was explained to me
and the way I understand it, is that,
you know how "League of Legends"
used to have a thing called
runes that weren't pay-to-win,
they would give you an edge,
but you could unlock
them through the game,
but they give you a noticeable
advantage, I'd say, at times.
Like back in the day, 'cause
you had to buy runes, remember?
- Yeah.
- Would you have described
runes as pay-to-win back then?
It's kind of like that.
- I mean, it's like,
with the advantages the
runes gave back in the day,
you wouldn't be able to take advantage
of that small stat increase
unless you're at the fucking higher tiers
where its truly optimized it.
- Yeah, it's kind of like that.
The game's just came out
and no one's really had the time to grind
to get the stuff,
so if you do just buy it,
you do get an advantage.
It's not massive, but
I don't know how big it is.
I mean, from what I
understand, it's not that much.
I mean, obviously any advantages
should be a big no-no
in video games, I think.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Especially a children's game as well.
- (laughs) It's like that.
(Garnt laughs)
You know, what's next?
Fucking "Tetris" with the
micro-transactions in it?
Like what are we doing?
- Well, I mean, you know,
technically speaking,
that's not the first Pokemon game
with micro-transactions, right?
Remember "Pokemon Go" back in the day?
- Yeah, and even then,
I felt like that was
like, it's weird, man.
It's just strange.
I feel like Nintendo, they're like,
"Well, if another company
develops it, it's not us."
- That is true, that is true.
"Pokemon Go" was also not them.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- But then Nintendo also does
weird other micro-transactions
or brand partnerships,
like they have fucking
Mercedes in "Mario Kart 8."
- Oh, yeah, yeah, oh, yeah.
- What the hell is with Mercedes?
- I remember that shit.
- Like what was going on with that?
What?
- I thought it was like a joke
that someone at the dev team threw in,
then I realized, oh no,
it's an actual brand, like.
- How did this happen?
What's going on?
It actually baffles me.
I mean, whatever, I don't give a shit.
- I pick it every time I play "Mario Kart"
just 'cause it's hilarious-
- Yeah, it looks so stupid.
- To see fucking baby Mario in a Mercedes.
- Yeah, just a full
Mercedes, that's so absurd.
- I never played "Mario Kart 8"
so this is the first
time I'm hearing of this.
- It's like a dead-ass Mercedes
with the logo and everything.
- Was it just a Mercedes?
- It's the car, just a Mercedes car,
it's like three Mercedes cars.
- And it's just hilarious
to see baby Mario-
- How did that happen?
- I don't know, it's bizarre.
- But it's just in the game?
- In the game.
- Always? Since release?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's not even like an unlockable,
it's just there by default.
- What?
- You can just pick a
Mercedes if you want.
- What?
- Yeah.
- [Connor] You didn't know this?
- I thought you guys were meme-ing.
- No, it's legit.
- No, no, no,
it's a straight up Mercedes.
- What the fuck is going on?
- When you select the cars,
it literally says Mercedes.
- You can even see the logo.
- Where does this fit in
the fucking Mario law?
How did this happen?
- You know, Mario was like,
"I'm sick of going
through all these levels.
Let me just hop in my Mercedes."
(Garnt laughs)
- It is bizarre.
- Running over all the enemies.
- You know, at least EA you
know what you're getting into.
You know, I mean, with Nintendo,
I can't figure out what the
fuck they're trying to do.
I don't know what they're doing.
- Everything. They're trying
to do everything, man.
- It's just bizarre.
I mean, I get it, whatever.
- I mean, good on them, I guess, man.
- Yeah, whatever, go get that grind.
- Get that coin, man.
- I just think unfortunately
micro-transactions is just
kind of creeping its way
into the future of gaming.
- Yeah, which is sad
'cause Nintendo obviously
was the one company
that for a long time was like, "No."
- Yeah, no.
- Yeah.
- But then now they're
like, "Yes, yes, yes."
- Yes.
- 'Cause Genshin's come along
and just proved how much
fucking money there is
to spend on anime waifu's apparently.
It's ridiculous.
'Cause I remember I
watched the live stream
of the new Genshin announcement
for the 2.0, Inazuma,
where they announced the new area.
And I think it was getting almost-
- It was 400,000 people.
- Yeah, 400,000 people.
- Fuck me, wow.
- On Twitch.
- On Twitch, not YouTube.
Twitch, live, concurrent.
- That's kinda crazy.
- Which is like,
how much does press conferences on EA
or press conferences on E3 and stuff get?
- Oh, not that much.
- It's not that much.
- 100K max.
- Yeah, it's like 100K, 200K maybe.
A Genshin update stream
was getting 400K viewers
concurrent on Twitch.
What the fuck is going on?
- Which, mind you,
a lot of the stuff that they announced
had already been leaked as well.
So it's like people are tuning
into at league shipping,
like it's confirmed, I guess.
- Yeah, I mean,
I'm sure if I was a fan
I'd get behind the hype.
I'd be very happy for it, but
I don't really play it, so.
- I mean, yeah, obviously it
did very well for them, right?
But, yeah, it just blew me away
'cause I was like, "Oh, there's
a Genshin stream happening
with 400,000 people
just sitting there waiting
for a fucking update?"
Like, are you serious?
- And now more Gacha.
Whoa, yes.
- Yeah, more waifus.
- Yeah, I mean, like I haven't
gotten back into Genshin,
I've been thinking about
it 'cause of the new area,
but, you know.
- Don't do it, man.
- Out of the three of us,
the person who was most into
Genshin was probably me.
And you acknowledge
this is a lot of people
watching an anime waifu game right now.
- Could you imagine if
"Fate/Grand Order" had an update
and those 400,000 people were watching it?
- Don't do that to me.
Don't give me hope. (laughs)
- Is Genshin is it, sorry,
is it majoritively played on mobile or PC?
- I'm assuming PC.
Actually, I don't know.
Honestly, this is a complete assumption.
- Yeah, we don't know, right?
- Of half the people I
know that play Genshin,
half of them play on mobile.
- Seriously?
- Like all of my Japanese
friends who play Genshin
play on mobile.
- Oh, god.
- I thought it would be
more majoritively PC.
- I mean you'd think so, right?
- Yeah, because I did not have a fun time
playing Genshin on mobile at all.
- I think some people
just play it on both.
Like when they're home,
they'll play it on PC,
but sometimes, you know,
they gotta get on that
grind while on the go,
they gotta play on mobile.
- One of the biggest
advantages that Genshin has
over a lot of AAA games,
which is the fact that it's
so fucking easy to play.
You know, like every account is linked,
and now you can even link your PS4 account
to every other account,
so it just makes it
ridiculously easy to play.
- Is it on the Switch as well?
- Not yet, no.
- It sounds like we're
reading an ad-read. (laughs)
- (laughs) It does, doesn't it?
- Is it on the Switch?
- Yeah, and apparently
there's a lot more characters.
- Did you know there's a
new area you can go to?
(everyone laughing)
- This is the problem when I'm a fan,
I have a lot of the things
I also end up promoting,
unfortunately.
- Yeah, right?
- I've fully disconnected
myself from gaming hype.
I don't get hyped about games anymore.
- [Joey] Yeah, me neither.
- I don't know if that
means no happiness for me,
but I've just stopped getting hyped
and I've stopped watching
announcements for video games.
- I think I've just stopped
getting hyped about things
in general 'cause I've just-
- That's kind of sad.
(Garnt laughs)
- It is kind of sad.
- It's called pessimism.
- Because I've ran into so many situations
where I just get hyped
and I either experience hype fatigue or-
- Fatigue. (laughs)
- Fatigue.
(Garnt laughs)
- It's fatigue, okay.
So I either experience hype fatigue,
or I just end up getting disappointed
with the final result, right?
And I'm just like, "Oh,
well then, what the fuck?"
You know, give me back my hype, right?
So now I'm-
- Give me back my hype.
- Yeah, I want a refund,
I want a refund. (laughs)
- Refund all my hype, please.
- I'm still waiting for my
"Cyberpunk" hype refund.
- I'm firmly of the mindset
you should never pre-order a game ever.
- No.
- Never.
- No matter how good or
100% it looks amazing
or the bonus deals, don't do it.
It's a bad practice and I
think it's bad for gaming.
(Garnt chuckles)
- It is.
- Here we go, here we go.
- It's bad for gaming, man.
It sucks.
- I mean, 'cause I'm not into gaming
as much as I used to be,
and even back then,
I don't think I've ever pre-ordered a game
or at least like,
I think the only game I ever
tried pre-ordering was GTA.
But that was just because it was GTA.
- Yeah.
- Oh, yeah, of course.
- Also do you remember?
Picture it, year 2013,
everything is a pre-order bonus.
Literally everything is pre-order.
Like everyone is pre-ordering everything.
That's just how it is.
You pre-order fucking everything.
Luckily now everyone's chilled out,
but it was insane back then.
- But I also think, kind of back then,
it made more sense, right?
Because back then,
the game you're buying on the day
was the game you were getting, right?
There was no updates,
no patches, no nothing.
- And it also made more sense 'cause
I think it really hit
its peak right before,
maybe just during online
shopping started popping up.
- Yeah.
- Right, right.
- You know, and this was before,
when you didn't really wanna download it
'cause people's internet speeds
really weren't good enough
to really download a full 20 gigabyte game
and stuff like that.
But now, you know,
people's internet speeds,
it's not really a problem.
- Yeah, and also back then,
I feel like you just had a lot less choice
of what games you could play, you know.
As a kid, I'm just like, yeah,
I waited for fucking five
months for the new Mario game
'cause there was nothing
else to look forward to.
There's literally nothing
to fill that void.
I couldn't get a free to play
game like Genshin. (laughs)
- Free to play game, that's just-
- It's free to play? (laughs)
- Like "Fortnite" or "League of Legends"
or anything like that.
There was nothing to fill up that void.
- I think the only games
that I've pre-ordered
are the ones that I know
100% I'm going to love.
- I've ordered every single
Mario release of late
and I haven't played any of them.
(Joey chuckles)
- Oh, that sounds like
your problem too. (laughs)
- I don't know why.
They brainwashed me.
- I think the last game I pre-ordered
was "Final Fantasy VII R"
but I 100-percented that 'cause
I knew I was gonna like it
'cause I liked the original.
And "Persona 5 Royal" as
well, I pre-ordered that
because I liked "Persona 5."
- I have so many fucking
games that I've bought
in my library that I just haven't-
- Oh, yeah, same.
- I've downloaded them,
I've installed them,
and I just never opened them.
Like I've never opened them.
- When was the last time you
got really hyped for a game?
- "Final Fantasy VII R" probably.
- Did it live up to your hype?
- Yeah, I 100-percented it.
It was fantastic.
- What about you, Garnt?
When was the last time
you pre-ordered a game
and got very excited about it?
- I haven't pre-ordered...
Like the last time I got
hyped for a game, "Cyberpunk."
(Joey and Connor laughing)
I'm not joking.
That was the last time
I got hyped for a game.
- And everybody laughed.
(Connor laughing)
Everybody laughed.
- That's a good one.
- And you know why I still
haven't even played it.
- I beat sci-fi, I don't give a shit.
It's a fucking terrible game, oh my god.
(Joey laughs)
- No, because I was just like,
"Great, it's a sci-fi game,
it's 'Cyberpunk.'
this looks like everything
I've ever wanted
to fill up that void
that 'Mass Effect' has
just left me for years."
- And now that hole is
even deeper. (laughs)
- And now the hole is even fucking deeper.
- It's a shame
you couldn't pre-order therapy
with it as well. (laughs)
- Comes with a free psychiatrist.
- No, I'm like, every few months,
I just Google, "Is
Cyberpunk 2077 playable?"
- I saw a good article.
It was like,
"'Cyberpunk' is nowhere near
a 'No Man's Sky' turnaround."
- (laughs) Oh, brutal.
- The devs are like, "We're
nowhere near fixing it."
Like "No Man's Sky" did
something like that,
according to something like that.
And they had to say a "No
Man's Sky" turnaround.
- Well, yeah, of course.
- Oh.
- I mean that is like,
"No Man's Sky" is the
fucking anime redemption
of the gaming industry.
I think it's one of the only redemption-
- That's when the antagonists
turned into the protagonists.
(everyone laughs)
- Because most companies,
you just cut your losses
and you're like, "Fuck it, make
the next fucking 'Fallout.'"
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Fuck 76, make a new one.
You know, that's how it is.
- Well, when was the
last time you got hyped?
- Yeah, as the gamer?
- (sighs) "Borderlands 3."
I was very hyped for "Borderlands 3."
- Oh, okay.
- Was it good?
- Uh, no.
- Oh, really?
- I was extremely hyped
for "Borderlands 3."
"Borderlands 2" is one
of my favorite games.
(Garnt sighs)
- Yeah, yeah, 'cause I was gonna ask.
I've never played 3, but I've played 2,
and 2 was great.
- Have you played 2?
- I haven't played "Borderlands 2."
- What was the sigh there, Garnt?
That was a dramatic sigh.
- I just realized what the game
before "Cyberpunk 2077-"
- Okay, we'll get into it.
- What the last game I
was hyped before that.
- "Borderlands 2," right?
I loved "Borderlands."
So I bought "Borderlands
1" originally on Xbox 360,
and I thought it was shit.
I hated it 'cause I didn't
have friends to play with.
So it was a terrible game to play alone.
But when I finally went
back to it, months later,
my friends bought 'cause it
went on more sale, cheap as art,
and, yeah, I loved it.
I thought, "Wow, okay,
this game is actually sick
when you play it with friends."
Then "Borderlands 2" came out
and it looked like they
just improved everything.
And they did.
And it was amazing.
"Borderlands 2" is such a good game
and playing it with friends is amazing.
Like this game is so much
replay value with friends.
And I absolutely had some
of the best gaming memories
playing "Borderlands 2."
So naturally,
"Borderlands 3" was coming out
and I had a monster
gaming PC, I was ready.
All my friends were getting it.
There was endless people
I could play with.
It was gonna be good.
So I play it and, yeah,
it's just kind of like "Borderlands 2"
but with a worse story.
Like the stuff they add isn't very good.
- Wait, since when have you
fucking cared about story?
- Well, "Borderlands 2"
actually was such like...
Handsome Jack is such an engaging villain.
But even when you don't
care about the story,
he's there, always making you laugh.
- [Joey] Right.
- And that was something that,
even if I didn't care what was happening,
I knew that I liked Handsome Jack
and that he was funny as fuck.
But I loved having that.
And the two main villains
were YouTubers or Twitch
streamers in the third one.
- Right.
- It was just cringe
'cause I'm a YouTuber and Twitch streamer,
so it was cringe watching them like-
- I am the bad guy. (laughs)
(Joey laughs)
- It was just like poking
fun at me in the worst way.
- [Joey] Right, right.
- And I was like, "This isn't this funny."
- This isn't the
representation I asked for.
- (laughs) This is slander.
(Garnt laughs)
- I'm all down
for when people make fun of
YouTubers and Twitch streamers.
I'm all down for it.
But sometimes they do it in a way where-
- Distasteful way, yeah.
- In a way where you've
clearly never watched something
because there are so many other things
you could have gone for.
You know, they do the whole thing
of like, "Oh, hi, guys," whatever,
and they could have gone for like,
"Why don't you thank me
for the $10 donation?"
or something like that.
That would've been funny as fuck.
You know, like Bo Burnham
did a great parody of it.
I mean, Bo Burnham used to
be a YouTuber, so obviously.
He did a great parody of
Twitch streamers and stuff,
and that was great,
but I felt like it was a terrible parody
and it was also, they
were just so unlikable
and there's so many bugs in it as well.
Like there's so many game-breaking bugs
that just happened throughout.
And I was like, "This
shouldn't be happening.
I waited years for this.
I got hyped for this.
I felt invested in this."
- Give my hype back.
- Also I didn't really
like any of the characters
that you could play as.
- Yeah.
- Which kind of sucked.
"Borderlands 2," I felt
like every single character
was like Pog.
- Yeah.
- That's how I got burnt.
- The game I got hyped for
before "Cyberpunk" was...
This just shows my track record
and why I don't get
hyped for games anymore.
It was "Mass Effect: Andromeda."
- I thought you were
about to say "Fallout 76."
(Garnt and Joey laughs)
- I thought you were
gonna say "No Man's Sky."
- Garnt's like, "'No
Man's Sky,' 'Fallout 76,'
'Mass Effect: Andromeda.'"
(Garnt laughs)
I love Dunkey's video.
I've never played "Mass Effect."
I've just watched Dunkey's videos on them.
And his video on "Andromeda" is so funny.
- I think I've played like an hour
of "Mass Effect: Andromeda"
and I'm just like, "This
just isn't doing it for me."
- [Joey] Right.
- By that point,
I think "Cyberpunk" was just a, yeah,
this looks like a game
that could appeal to me,
but I think "Mass Effect"
was really what just killed my soul
inside of me. (chuckles)
- Right, right.
- There's something so
heartbreaking about it
in a way that I've never experienced,
where the game just
lets you down like that.
- Yeah.
- It feels like your dad just
never came home, you know?
Like it's like, damn.
- But it's like, it feels
like your dad came home,
but with a different woman.
(everyone laughs)
- A new son.
This is you now, alright?
I feel like that's the first time
you get to really experience
betrayal as a young adult.
A true betrayal.
(Garnt giggling)
- I trusted you. I followed
you all the way through,
and this is how you repay me?
- I stuck with you for years.
I had memories with you that I can't,
I've never even had with anyone else,
and this is how you repay me?
It's gone like that.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I mean,
now I just try to keep as little knowledge
of the gaming industry and
what's coming out as possible
because I've kind of realized
my favorite gaming experiences recently
have just been games
that I had no idea about
until they were out.
- I didn't know anything
about "Breath of the Wild"
and it blew me away.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah, didn't know anything
about "Breath of the Wild."
I'm just like, it's been fucking,
I hadn't played Zelda since "Wind Waker"
and it was fucking amazing.
- Oh yeah.
"Horizon Zero Dawn"?
I was like, "What the fuck?
What kind of game franchise is this?"
I had no idea what it was about.
It was fucking amazing.
- That's why I'm not hyping myself up
for "Breath of the Wild 2," right?
Because I don't want a
fucking "Andromeda" to happen.
(Garnt laughs)
- Like God forbid it ever happens,
but you never know, right?
So I'm just gonna wait.
I'm just gonna wait.
- Yeah, and also like,
obviously everyone's streaming a lot now.
You know, when E3 happens or
a Nintendo press conference,
everyone's like, "Oh, did you watch it?
Did you watch the E3 conference?"
Why would I watch an hour of ads?
Why?
(Joey laughs)
What, so I can get excited
and give my money to a company
that's gonna let me down?
No. No, thank you.
When the game comes out and I
hear it's good, I'll buy it.
- Yeah, why would I sit down
and watch an hour conference
of getting myself hyped for something
that I probably won't be hyped about?
- I don't know, I think it's pretty fun.
I'm not even invested in it.
- Sometimes it's fun.
- I'm just like, sometimes when...
Like I still remember
when "Final Fantasy VII
Remake" was announced
and just the reaction around that.
I'm just like, I don't give
a shit about "Final Fantasy,"
but I'm fucking hyped.
- Never mind me who never
played "Final Fantasy."
I'm like, "What's going on?
What's going on?"
(Garnt laughs)
- Meanwhile, I was the one
going, "Yeah," in the crowd.
- Yeah, and then they get announced
"Shenmue III" afterwards.
(Joey laughs)
(laughs) I was just like,
"What kind of a press conference is this?"
Like, I think I was more
hyped about press conference
than the actual games themselves.
- Yeah, "Shenmue III,"
that turned out to be a great game, huh.
- But I feel like it's a fun little event,
you know, if you take part of it.
I just feel like-
- I just don't wanna get hyped.
- It's like the Nintendo Directs, right?
That's like another one
where it's just like, "Did you watch it?
Did you watch the Nintendo Direct?"
- There's something about Nintendo Directs
that really pissed me off.
I can't put my finger on it.
I get angry watching Nintendo Direct.
- (chuckles) Why?
- I don't know why.
I think it's the way they present games
that clearly no one gives a shit about.
They'll be like, "And
now is 'Just Dance 17.'"
(Joey laughs)
And it's like, why?
- But they always have to sandwich it
between two big titles, right?
- Yeah.
- Which is fair enough, right?
- I understand.
- They clearly know,
but it's also just like, I don't
care about "Just Dance 76."
- Well, sometimes they
do ad spots, I think,
for other companies to,
where they give, I think it's an ad spot.
I think they do this.
And that they'll show
a game that looks awful
for like 30 minutes and
they'll do a play-through.
And I'm like, "Stop this,
stop this right now.
Show me an ad. Show me
an ad over this, please.
(Joey laughs)
Anything else other than this.
I can't stand this.
- Show me a Bud Light ad.
- I'll take it.
- I'll take a Bud Light ad.
- Give me a "Fallout
76" demo or something.
God damn it, please, I'm
begging for something else.
I don't know.
I think I'm just getting
to that point in my life
where I'm becoming extremely
bitter about everything
that makes other people happy.
- (laughs) Welcome to adulting.
- I think I'm getting to that point.
- It's called being adulting
and it's called being British as well.
It's like the worst combination.
- An old angry bastard is all you become.
- I think I sit there on my
porch, just rocking my chair,
thinking, "Oh, you young kids
getting excited over games,
how naive of you."
- Imagine being happy.
Imagine being excited.
- How naive of you.
- If only I could feel
these emotions anymore.
- Oh, you think "Mario
Golf" is gonna be fun?
Really?
Have fun playing "Mario Golf."
One time at a party and they're
never playing it ever again.
(Garnt laughs)
"Mario Tennis," you thought that was fun?
I never felt angrier than
when I bought "Mario Tennis,"
the new "Mario Tennis."
- Right.
- It's a fucking terrible game.
Have you played it?
- Yeah, I like it.
- It's terrible, it's terrible.
- Why?
- Well, why is it terrible?
- Wait, have you played
the original though?
- No.
- Well, that's probably why. (laughs)
- Why?
I have to have prerequisite
knowledge of another game?
- Well, compared to the
original, it's much better.
- I loved the original.
- I like the original too,
but I think the new one
just improved on it.
- I mean, I loved the
original 'cause I was a kid
and I had zero taste in video games.
Everything was fine.
(Joey laughs)
- I'm sure I pissed off a lot.
- I'm sorry I don't have
taste in video games, wow.
- I'm sure I pissed people
off saying it's terrible.
I played it
and I was so bored out of
my mind playing this game.
- Well, I mean,
clearly it's just not a
game made for you, right?
- Why?
Why is it not?
I would have loved this.
What's going on?
What's going on? Why do I hate this game?
- You sound like the same crowd of people-
- 'Cause it's not toxic enough for you.
- You sound like the same crowd
of people who are pissed off
when Nintendo released the Nintendo 2DS,
which was intended for
like, five-year-olds.
(Garnt and Connor laughs)
How dare Nintendo not release
a console made for me?
- I like the 2DS.
I thought it was affordable and, yeah,
I liked the ergonomics of it.
It looked cool.
- It looked like a fucking Fisher Price,
fucking like children's toy.
- Yeah, I liked it.
- And adults are like,
"What the fuck, Nintendo?
How dare you not make?
What is this?
I'm not gonna buy this."
- How dare you make a toy?
What are you, a toy company?
- I'm not one of those people
who gets angry at Nintendo
for not making adult-oriented products,
'cause that's not what they do.
But, you know, for stuff like Pokemon,
I wish that they would
put a difficulty option
or something where you could
add something, like that.
I wish they would include something.
- The toxic gamer is coming out right now.
- Is it insane of me to ask Pokemon
to include something that
makes it more difficult?
- Are you talking about "Pokemon Unite"?
- No, no, no, no.
- Or just Pokemon in general?
- The normal Pokemon.
- Well, the great thing about Pokemon
is that you can make it as
difficult as you fucking want.
That's the beauty of the game.
- Yeah, that's true.
- That's why Nuzlockes are a thing.
- I know, I know,
but I wish there was a way
the in-game was baked into it
that allows you to make it more difficult
or to do certain things.
I don't understand why-
- No, I don't think that's-
- I disagree with that.
- I disagree,
because I think purposely
leaving it open-ended
to how difficult you want it
is what makes that game
so appealing to people.
If you put a difficulty...
Like if you went into a Pokemon game
and you were like,
"Choose the difficulty,"
immediately people will be like, "Oh."
- Okay, actually, in
regards to difficulty,
I fucking hate choosing difficulty.
I hate it so much.
- I do hate it too.
- I hate it as well.
- It depends on the game.
It depends on the game,
because on some games,
it's completely stupid
and unnecessary, right?
Like first person shooters,
I hate it because it just
makes them more bullock-spongy.
- Yeah.
- That's all it does. But
on some games like Pokemon
where it's like, okay,
even a 12-year-old would
probably find this too easy,
like especially the new one.
The new one was like mind-
- Well, the new one's hold
your hand, that's why.
- It was beyond mind...
Like even like, you know,
you play "Platinum"-
- That's a problem with
the game itself, right?
It's just not difficult enough.
- Yeah, I feel like even adding
10% more difficulty to this
is like, what?
Like with "Pokemon Platinum,"
I was playing that, I did a Nuzlocke,
but even the core game itself
was actually kind of challenging.
You can't just fall asleep
and just spam one Pokemon.
- Well, that's the thing, right?
It's like, I feel that's the
problem with just Pokemon games
in general where like...
Like I played "Sun and Moon."
That shit holds your hand the entire way,
even as an adult.
- It's so insulting.
- And I'm like, dude,
like ten-year-old me was crying,
trying to get past the
June 3 of silver, right?
And the game didn't give a fuck.
It was just like, "Just get good."
- It's like, "Figure it out, you're 10.
You should start thinking, bro.
Use that fucking 10-year-old
thick skull of yours."
- Yeah, exactly.
- I feel like nowadays,
people have less patience
when it comes to completing games, man.
There's no way-
- But, oh, come on.
Making a Pokemon gym slightly harder
is hardly asking for like...
We're not adding in "Dark
Souls" level of difficulty
to a children's game.
You should in a Pokemon game,
I think even if you're like 10 years old,
you should fail the first gym probably
and be forced to be like, "Maybe
I should buy some potions.
Maybe I should consider doing something.
Not just fucking steamrolling this shit
with my Mudkip every time."
- Yeah, just give it good game design
so that you don't have to say anything
to get the player to figure it out, right?
- Even when I was a much younger kid,
you know, when I was 10,
whatever, playing these games,
I hated it when games were
completely steamrolling,
like you could just do
it without thinking.
It's like, having some form
of difficulty there is good.
And it's also important, I
think, for the kid to learn
that not everything is
gonna be fucking easy.
- Yeah, exactly.
Like I remember when I was
fucking eight years old
playing "Mega Man 2" for the first time.
And I was like, "This
is fucking impossible.
No one can beat this game."
- Dude, I fucking love that game though.
- It's one of my favorite
games of all time
because I learned success through failure.
- Kids have it too easy nowadays, guys.
- The problem is, right,
is that, as an adult,
I have absolutely zero patience
for games that are bullshit hard.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- Kids do not.
Kids will play the bullshit hard game
over and over and over again
because it's, one,
it's probably the only
game they're getting,
and also they love it.
- But it's not anymore.
It's not.
- That's the problem, it's not anymore.
- That's the point I'm trying to make.
- Well, I mean, if you're
mobile gaming, right?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- No, because I feel like there's just,
games are a lot more affordable nowadays.
Back then, you had one game
every few months maybe.
- But there's still,
if they're getting like
an Xbox or something,
okay, yeah, they can play
"Fortnite" for free on it.
But if they wanna buy another
game and it's difficult,
they're probably gonna try and complete it
'cause they bought the game or
they wanted it for Christmas
or something.
- Right.
Adults try to understand kids. (laughs)
- No, I'm just thinking
from my perspective.
I don't know. I mean, most
of them are just happy
with "Fortnite" and stuff, right?
- Right, right.
- Yeah.
- But I mean, you know.
- I think the other thing as well
is that at least with the
old games is that, you know,
because they could only be so long,
that they literally had
to be like, alright,
this game, if you blast through it,
you can probably complete
it in less than an hour.
- Exactly.
- But like, we want you to
play this game for a long time
so we're just gonna make it bullshit hard
to the point where 40 minutes of gameplay
is gonna take you about 40 days.
- Oh, there are a lot of bullshit moments
in a lot of older games.
- Oh, yeah.
- And I remember thinking back
and I'm thinking, "How the fuck did I play
so many levels of 'Battletoad'
and 'Contra'-
(Joey laughs)
- Did you actually play "Battletoad"?
- I did play "Battletoad."
- Oh my god.
- It's actually a really
fucking good game.
- Oh, it's a good game.
- Yeah, it's fucking great game.
- It's the shit.
- Like to this day,
I remember playing the
fucking motorbike, like the-
- Oh, the hoverboard.
- Yeah, the hoverboard level.
- That's a notorious level,
it's fucking impossible.
- I think I played it for
a full week, in my room,
trying to complete that fucking level.
- Yeah, 'cause I remember
beating "Mega Man 2"
lots of times as a kid.
And then I recently played
it a couple of years ago,
I could barely get past fucking Woodman.
And I'm like, "How the fuck did
I do this as a 10-year-old?"
Oh, it's because I literally
spent like a month of my life
just grinding this game.
- Also I can't play "Mega Man" at my age.
I'm gonna get fucking carpal tunnel.
(Joey laughs)
I tried playing "Mega Man X,"
I'm just like, "Oh, I'm
getting a fucking cramp here
from just doing the wall jump."
Jesus Christ.
My God. (laughs)
- It's great though, I love it.
- I guess I'm angry that I'm getting older
and these children games
aren't getting older with me.
- Yeah.
- I guess so.
- I mean, like with difficulty,
I now like when a game has
just one set difficulty,
even if it's easy,
even if it's steamrolling.
- No, I agree, I agree.
- I get anxious that
with any game or any piece of media
where I want to enjoy it the most, right?
I wanted to enjoy it the most
on my first play through.
And sometimes I've had games where
I load it up and I hit the
difficulty level selection
and I'm just like, "(inhales)
I'm getting anxiety just now.
(chuckles) I'm already getting anxiety.
You know what?
Maybe I'll play this
game another time, yeah."
- This is why I like games that,
even if they have difficulty options,
they let you just change it on the fly.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, I like that a lot.
- And there's consequences for it.
And it's like, "Alright, well,
this section is kind of
bullshit, I'ma knock it down."
- How do you feel about people
who purposely select easy mode?
- Well, it depends on the game.
There's some games where I'm like,
you're actually just not playing the game,
if you've pick the easy one
'cause it's far too easy.
- But, like, there's that whole stigma,
I guess, like, connotation,
that like, "Oh, you're not a real gamer
if you're playing it on easy mode.
Get good, scrub."
Like levels of things, but like-
- I mean, obviously if I was
there in the room with them,
I'd be like, "I'm a strong little baby.
I'm not gonna click normal?"
(Joey laughs)
But, you know, on the podcast,
and if a general audience asked me,
I'd be like, "Yeah, of course,
you can you pick whatever
difficulty you want."
But obviously if you're my
mate, I'm gonna rinse you.
- Play baby mode 'Mario Kart.'
- I'm like, "Are you playing 'Mario Kart'
with baby mode on?"
No, you're not.
- No, you're not.
No, no, no, no, no. (laughs)
- No, no, no. Yeah, I mean,
it's different, right?
Obviously you'll poke fun at your friends,
you'll fuck around with it.
- Yeah, of course, of course.
But obviously in general,
I think that you can play
whatever fucking difficulty you want.
I don't give a fuck.
Why would I care?
What does it take away from me?
- Just have fun.
Just have fun with the game.
- Yeah, exactly.
- If you wanna be a little baby bitch,
you can be a little baby bitch.
I don't care. You have
the right to do that.
You paid the 60 bucks.
- You have the right to be a baby bitch.
- You paid the 60 bucks, you get to do it.
I think it's good 'cause
not everyone, you know,
obviously some people
have disabilities as well.
They can't play the game
on the hardest difficulty
'cause maybe they can't do it.
You know, I just think
accessibility is good in gaming.
I think that one of the things
that pisses me off most,
and it's always the Japanese
game companies that do this,
is it like the accessibility
options in their games
are terrible.
Like they don't let you change anything.
No button remapping, none of that.
I love it when games are like,
"Bro, what do you wanna do?
How big do you want the
character models to be?
No, not that, sorry.
How bold do you want the outlines to be?
- Do you ever use button remapping?
- Yeah, all the time.
- Really?
I've never used it.
- I've never used it in my life.
- I love button remapping.
And it pisses me off that
a lot of games don't do it.
And a lot of the indie devs
are normally the ones who include
a shit ton of accessibility options.
- But that's a lot of PC games as well.
Not a lot of console games
have button remapping, right?
- Yeah, I mean, the
beauty of console games
is that it's just plug and play.
It's very simple.
Just put a disc in or whatever,
or you download the game,
and you just start playing.
- Okay, so the argument
behind accessibility options
and button remapping especially,
especially with people who are,
you know, maybe someone has a disability
where they can't use one
of their hands properly
and maybe there's a button
where they can't press jump,
but they can press the jump
button with this finger.
So the idea is that,
even though, yes, this is
probably the best layout,
someone out there might
have a way easier time
with this button being on this one, right?
So just give them the option to remap it.
- No, no, no, yeah.
- Why wouldn't you?
- Yeah.
No, I'm definitely not
against button remapping,
I've just personally never used it, yeah.
- Yeah, Nintendo's gotten
a lot better at it as well,
I think, actually, I think so.
But they're awkward sometimes with it.
And also colorblind options.
"The Last of Us" had amazing
accessibility options.
Like you could change it
so everything in the
thing was just two colors.
Like it's all gray
and the models are just bright red
and bright blue.
- Oh, that's cool.
- So even someone who's
completely like, you know,
has a really bad a case of
vision can play the game
'cause they can see the
models' outlines and stuff.
And then you can also just
turn stuff on for yourself,
like if you prefer color...
Like a lot of people play "Apex Legends"
with the colorblind settings on
to change the color of the bars and stuff
to make it more visible, you know?
I think that especially...
Oh, another one. Okay, sorry,
I'm doing another rant now.
This is one thing that I think
there's absolutely no excuse
why there shouldn't be an option
on every single video game.
Subtitles.
Why is there not subtitles
on every single video game?
They have the script.
- Yeah, I hate it.
- I agree with that.
- I hate games that don't have subtitles.
- Sometimes I don't wanna
have to listen to it
at full volume,
and sometimes maybe there's
explosions and shit going on,
I want to read it.
They have the script,
just plop that shit in.
- It's just like, what is
it about, not just gaming,
but movie audio mixing,
especially if you're like...
- Oh yeah.
- I remember I watched the
"Night Crawlers" yesterday
with Sydney and, you know,
we watched a few movies.
And we turned up the TV
to almost full volume.
Character starts speaking, and
it was just like, (mumbles).
(Joey laughs)
I'm just like, "What?
What?
Is there a subtitle option?"
And then we turn on the TV to full volume
and it's still like, (mumbles).
And suddenly, out of nowhere,
boom, boom, boom.
I'm getting earache right now.
What the hell's going on?
- I had some compression
on this shit, my god.
- I literally had that happen to me
when I watched "Interstellar" last week.
(Connor laughing)
Like, oh my god,
it's a fantastic movie,
don't get me wrong,
and I love Matthew McConaughey,
but, man, listening to him
is like listening to a
subwoofer that barely works.
This is like (imitates subwoofer).
- 'Cause when they're mixing these movies,
they're mixing them on these
gigantic audio editing suites
where you can hear everything.
And I'm like, "No, edit this
on a fucking ear port, bro,
so you can hear what most
people are gonna listen to,
like when they're listening to this."
- I'm like, it's this
amazing scene, you know,
when Matthew McConaughey is giving this
really intense speech,
and all I'm hearing is
just these fucking organs.
And it's just like, "Ah."
And Matthews like, (mumbles),
Like, I don't know what
you're saying. (laughs)
Speak up.
(Garnt and Connor laughing)
- 'Cause I suppose some of the time,
like the audio mixing
online video games as well,
it's like watching a bass-boosted meme.
(Connor and Joey laughing)
You know, where the dialogue is so quiet
and your ears just get fucking destroyed.
(Joey growling)
- Yeah, I fucking love YouTube
videos from small YouTubers
whose audio is way too fucking quiet
and the music is like, dun, dun, dun, dun,
do, do, do, do, do,
and you can't fucking hear them.
I dunno why I love it.
- It's my favorite.
- It's so charming.
- I know, it's so pure.
I love it.
- Yeah, subtitles on video games.
This is why we need it,
even in your own language, right?
- Yeah, yeah, so there should
be absolutely no reason
why there shouldn't be subtitles,
'cause they have to write
the script for the game.
Just put the fucking script
into the software that can do this.
Yeah, someone has to time
it, okay, that sucks, but-
- And I hate how it's, like,
a lot of games, the default is off.
Just make it on,
and if you don't like it,
then you can turn it off.
- Also, I think a lot of
games as well do this,
and I think every game should do this,
is that they let you choose
how big you want the text,
the color of the text,
the outline of the text,
the shadow and stuff,
so you can get the subtitles just right.
So, you know, again,
if you can't really see very
well, you know, you should...
I don't understand why
games don't just give
you all these options.
I get it, it's a crunch,
they don't have time,
but I mean, it's like, "Alright,
well, just fuck the people
who can't play the game
like everyone else, right?
Just fuck them, right?
Yeah, fuck them."
Which is why everyone
loves to clown on Xbox,
and I get it.
You know, I'm an Xbox
boy myself, I love Xbox.
I think Xbox have done some
of the most amazing things
for accessibility.
Have you seen the controller they've made?
It's like this pad, right,
and you can literally
hook anything up to it,
literally anything into a controller.
And it's set up
so that you can just turn
anything into a controller
so that no matter how your position is
or what disability you have,
you can set it up
so that you can get a way
where you can play games.
- [Joey] Oh, that's cool.
- And it's like, they have
so many mods with it as well,
so they have inbuilt mods.
But you can do anything.
It's so cool. Could you
pull it up, Nabby, actually?
What's it called?
- Thought you were
talking about the elite.
- Could you get the coffee,
actually, real quick
while I bring it up?
- Yeah, okay.
- This episode is sponsored by ZenMarket.
- Gentlemen, have you ever come across
an exclusive piece of anime merch
that you could only get in Japan
and you wanted it so bad
that it kills you inside?
- I'm glad I'm alive
because I'm here in Japan
so I'm not being killed
because we have lovely stuff,
like the exclusive JoJo
suit and the JoJo watch,
which Joey is wearing right now.
- I wear it every day.
That's how exclusive it is.
- And those are bad-ass (indistinct) bags
you can't get, but you could have got,
if you'd gone to ZenMarket earlier.
And you see these exclusive glam shirts
(Joey gasps)
only ship to Japan,
like this Asuka shirt
and basically the JoJo
shirts merch we wear
every other episode.
- Wouldn't you want to get one?
- Well, gentlemen, worry no more,
because the sponsor for
today's episode, ZenMarket,
has your back.
- Ooh.
- With ZenMarket, there's
no need to live in Japan
or even know any Nihongo.
- That's me.
- Because ZenMarket takes
care of everything for you.
- [Garnt] All you have
to do is place an order
with any Japanese online store
and ZenMarket will receive your item,
shipping it wherever you live,
using your choice of
international courier.
- [Connor] Only a flat
fee of 300 yen per item?
- That's like, $3.
- Damn.
- You're basically living in Japan.
(Joey gasps)
- Also for a limited time of two weeks,
they are holding a summer discount
for all of their customers
where each one of you can
get a one-time 25% discount
off international shipping
by using the coupon code
ZEN25 during checkout.
- Getting all these juicy exclusive anime
and manga goodies has
never been this easy.
- Delicious.
- So what are you waiting for?
Go over to our very own
"Trash Taste" landing page,
link in description down below,
and start exploring Japanese snacks,
clothing, and electronics,
and so much more today.
Back to the episode.
- Yeah, Xbox made this controller
called the Xbox Adaptive Controller
and you can literally just
plug anything you want,
like a massive button,
something that you blow on,
literally anything you want.
- That's so cool.
Is this recent?
- It's been out for like two, three years.
- Oh, wow.
- It's been around for a while.
- Never heard of it.
- And it's done some amazing things.
It's so cool that Xbox thought to do that
because they're probably not
gonna make much money off that.
Yeah, that's not something
you make money off of
so a lot of the companies won't do it.
But, you know, I thought, fuck,
fair play to Microsoft, man.
- I mean, yeah, that's great cred, right?
- Yeah,
just like, why wouldn't you do that?
It's a great idea.
- They're looking out
for all gamers out there.
- And also, you know, a
lot of the stuff that Xbox-
- (giggling) It's just we were
talking about serious stuff,
but just the way, "They're
looking out for all gamers."
- I meant that with sincerity.
- (laughs) It just sounds so facetious.
(everyone laughs)
Like the term "gamers" has
just, like, been ruined.
- That's what it means.
(Garnt laughing)
- For the record, I meant that
in all sincerity, alright.
Please.
- Any game company or whatever
that spends money and time
to develop stuff for accessibility options
that they know is probably
not gonna be valued
by 99% of people,
that's mad respect, you know?
- Yeah, of course.
- It deserves to be praised.
- I feel like in terms of
customization and accessibility,
well, maybe not accessibility,
but definitely customization,
it's always been the PC gaming crowd
that's been leading the charge,
and, you know, obviously
Xbox Microsoft, you know.
It kind of feels like
it fits within their IP.
Whereas Nintendo is kind of like
the Apple of the gaming world,
where it's like, "This is
how we're doing things.
You can buy peripherals.
You can't buy your own peripherals.
It's always gotta be our peripherals."
- It sucks, right?
'Cause imagine it, like Miyamoto's there,
this kid who can't use his hands,
and Miyamoto's like, "Yeah, you
don't get to play my games."
(Joey chuckles)
Why? Oh, 'cause you
don't make enough money.
Do you make money? Do you
make millions of dollars?
No, bye-bye.
That's just like, why would
you deny someone the option
to get to play your games?
You know, I'd like to think
that if something happened to me
or, you know, if I had
a kid who loved gaming
and he wasn't able to use
the standard controller,
I'd wanna think that there's a chance
that he can play his favorite
games, you know what I mean?
I said "he" like I know it's a boy.
Of course it's gonna be a boy.
I wouldn't allow it.
(everyone laughs)
- Ew, girls, daughters,
disgusting. (laughs)
- I don't know, no excuse.
- Gamer girls, ugh.
Those don't exist.
- Ugh. (laughs)
- It's not hard to make
something that's like that,
that you can just allow
someone to customize, you know?
Obviously you still need
help from someone else
to help set it up for you,
but, I mean, I don't know.
- Why not?
- It pisses me off when they won't do it.
- Like all these companies
have all this money, right?
Like at least spend it on
something that, you know.
- Yeah, like Nintendo at one point,
I think it was a year ago,
it was the most cash rich
company in Japan. (laughs)
- I mean, dude, that pandemic
did fucking wonders for them.
- They have cash laying around.
Make a fucking accessible
controller, Nintendo.
Fuck me.
Stop making Joy-Cons that
don't fucking work. (chuckles)
Goddamn it.
(Joey laughs)
- Stop making Joy-Cons that
break after six months.
- [Connor] Jesus.
- It literally is like an Apple periphery.
- It is, it is.
- Yeah.
- It's just like, oh, it
breaks after six months,
just buy a new pair.
Just buy a new pair.
- I had a friend who was like,
he didn't know anything about
Joy-Con drift, any of that.
and they were like, "Yeah,
I don't know why your-
- What's Joy-Can drift?
. You don't know anything
about Joy-Con drift?
- I obviously don't play my Switch enough.
- It's when the D-pad just stops working.
- So unfortunately there's
a massive lawsuit going on,
I don't know if it's been resolved,
with Nintendo and a bunch.
It's a class action.
Essentially, the controllers,
after a random period of time,
they just start drifting the Joy-Con,
like the joystick on its own.
- Right.
- It's not just the Joy-Cons either.
The Pro Controllers do the same thing.
- Yeah, yeah.
And it's been a massive problem
and people have to buy so many Joy-Cons.
And Joy-Cons aren't cheap.
They're like 60 bucks.
- 60, 70 bucks, yeah.
- It's ridiculous.
Yeah, and they just, they drift.
And I had a friend who was playing it,
and bless them, they're
not really a gamer,
and they were like, "Yeah,
so when I'm playing it,
sometimes I just go to the side.
Why is that?"
(Joey chuckles)
I'm like, "First time, huh?"
(Joey laughs)
Yeah, so Nintendo made a shitty product
that doesn't fucking work
so you have to deal with it.
Buy a new one if you don't like it.
- Spend more money.
- Yeah, Nintendo says
they'll fix it as well,
that they have like warranty or...
- I don't know.
- I don't wanna deal with that shit.
- I think the last thing
that something like that happened to me
was the infamous Xbox red rings of death.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
- Bro, that was such a debacle.
- I know. (laughs)
- I like how we completely
forgot about it.
- What a fucking clown
fiesta that was, man.
- Yeah.
- Did you have to send your
Xbox away to Microsoft?
- No, no.
So like I did this like,
fucking guerilla tactic
that I found on the internet of,
now that I know what I'm doing,
I was just basically overheating the Xbox.
So what you do is you fucking
wrap a towel around it
and then...
No, I'm actually serious.
- What? (laughs)
- You wrap a towel around it
and then you turn on the Xbox
and leave it for like a few hours.
So you're just basically overheating it.
- You're cooking it.
- Yeah, you're overheating
or cooking your fucking CPU or something.
- You should have like a 4chan thread
to set your house on fire.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
Like, what the fuck?
- Yeah, very, very much
like a fire hazard.
- How to be an arsonist with an Xbox.
- But some reason,
for some inexplicable reason, it worked.
And I have no idea why.
- Wait, wait,
so do you wanna explain what
the red ring of death is
for people who don't know?
- So back when Xbox
released their Xbox 360-
- They rushed it out and
it was poorly manufactured.
It had many problems.
- Right, so if you bought
one of the first consoles,
first generation consoles
that were released,
you basically had a time limit, right?
It was basically like a year or two.
And every Xbox had this, where you play,
and then one day, for one
reason that nobody could tell,
it just wouldn't work.
And so you would get
the three rings, right?
So when the Xbox turns on, right,
you'd see a green ring
around the power button.
And basically it was
split into four segments.
And the red rings of death
meant three segments were red,
which would mean something
was wrong with the start-up.
And we called it the red rings of death
because everyone had this issue
and it never got resolved.
And how you would resolve it,
is to basically send it
back to the manufacturer.
- Yeah, it cost Microsoft
billions 'cause of all this shit,
'cause it happened so often.
And my friend, I had
two friends who had it,
so we had a group of four
of us who all played Xbox.
And I never got it, thank God.
I would have actually cried,
'cause what my friend had to go through
sounded like my worst
nightmare as 16-year-old me.
He got the red ring of death
and he had to send it back.
And then they sent back a box,
an Xbox that was refurbished
and it was someone else's
and it didn't work.
- What?
- And, again, like they're-
- So they're just recycling Xboxes?
- Apparently they were
doing stuff like this.
It was pretty widespread.
- Jeez.
- So he sent it and he called them up.
Again, this is like, over months.
I think it took like half a year
to get it fixed, overall.
- Jesus.
- He had to send it about three times
before they finally fixed it.
And then it broke six months later
and he just gave up.
He was like, "I'm not doing it again.
I'm not sending it back."
- Yeah, fucking hell.
- I mean, that literally
scared me to death.
I was like, the thought of my Xbox dying.
I was like, this is my lifeline.
Like, if this goes, what am I gonna do?
I don't know what I'm going to do.
If I can't play "Halo: Reach,"
I'm gonna to lose it.
(Joey laughs)
It's gonna be everyone's problem.
- Do you remember memory cards?
- Yeah.
- Have you ever had like a save file
that's just been corrupt?
- Actually trauma from my childhood
of my fucking GameCube ones
just dying for no reason.
- Yeah, yeah.
- The GameCube ones died
all the fucking time.
- The GameCube ones died constantly.
- The GameCube ones were
the worst, oh my God.
- I remember I just ended
up with a pile of them.
- Do you know why?
It's 'cause I bought the Mad Catz ones.
- Ah, I see.
- Back in the day,
Mad Catz was like, everything.
Like if you wanted controller
or another memory card
or any peripheral that was
half the price, Mad Catz.
- So we have like the Xbox now,
not the Xbox, sorry, the
GameCube in our room right now.
And I was like, "Oh, okay,
I gotta buy some memory cards for it."
And the trauma kicks back.
The moment I said that to myself,
I was like, "We've gotta buy memory cards.
We've gotta buy memory cards."
I just ended up buying
like 10 memory cards,
'cause I was like, I'm
just expecting the worst.
One of these memory cards is gonna die
in like, two days, guaranteed.
Luckily it hasn't happened yet.
So I just have this like pile
of memory cards in my room
that are just unused, just in case.
But, yeah, it sucked as well
because there was no pattern to it.
- No, there wasn't.
There was never a pattern.
- It's was just one day the
memory card was like, "See ya."
- Yeah.
- See ya, peace.
- Yeah, I think playing with
memory cards on the GameCube
has given me a permanent
fear of playing JRPGs.
(Joey laughs)
Like it was like, you know, "Mario Kart,"
you know, fucking any Zelda game.
Okay, Zelda's bad enough, okay, but like-
- Oh, dude,
like I've had some "Wind Waker" accounts
just completely die on me for no reason.
- But there is nothing worse
than a fucking JRPG corrupting.
And I've had it.
I've had it on GameCube,
I've had it on PS2.
I still have never finished "Star Ocean 3"
because I've gotten fucking
60 hours into the game,
I was invested,
and then the memory card got corrupted
and I just lost 60 hours of my life
and I've never gotten it back
and I don't know what the
ending of that game is.
- I had it even worse once.
I think it was the second time
I played a "Final Fantasy" game.
I was playing "Final Fantasy VI"
for the first time on Super Nintendo,
and I was like, 40 hours in.
I think I was maybe two bosses away.
And just one of my cousins walked past,
kicked the SNES, and
completely reset my file.
- What the fuck?
- Just like a light tap,
like that.
It just went, blip, just died.
And I was like, "What happened?"
Flicked it back on, corrupt, all gone.
- Bro.
- And I was like,
I'd never been that close to
committing murder in my life.
(everyone laughing)
But I was that close.
Like, eight-year-old me was like,
"Is this how serial murders start?"
- Joey was a good boy until the day.
- Until he wasn't. (laughs)
- Until that day
when someone kicked his SNES.
- And then that's when I realized
just the absolute fragility
of these old consoles.
They're literally just a tiny...
It wasn't even like a boot.
It was literally just
like a little light tap.
- It was either you had an absolute tank
or you got very unlucky
and one tap did it.
Like I swear to God,
I dropped my Nintendo DS like
a million times as a child
and it never broke.
- Oh, dude, those things
are brick shithouses.
- Don't know how it never broke,
but somehow, you know,
my PS2 would just shit
itself all the time.
But I swear everyone
else's PS2 was a tank.
So I don't really understand.
- For some reason,
always the Sony ones were
just the most fragile things.
Like being a Nintendo kid-
- Xbox 360s, I've seen like
how those things survive,
I don't even know, man. Even
though the red ring of death,
like, I don't know.
Garnt, I'm sorry.
- I know, like, dude,
did you ever have that experience
on a PS2 where, you know,
you go up to the loading screen
and then you put the disk
in and you just like,
you're praying for a
few seconds of silence.
You're praying to God
that you're gonna get the shoop. (laughs)
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And when you don't, you have this,
it's like this fucking
hellish dimension, right,
where the PS2 just turns
into the gates of, like,
the fucking gates of hell open up.
(Joey laughs)
It's all red,
and you're just like, "Oh, I've
got a corrupt disk, oh no."
- How do you even do that?
How do you get a corrupt disk?
How does that even happen?
- Oh, how do you not do that?
Have you never had a faulty disk?
- Even the OG Xboxes,
if there was one micrometer of dust on it.
- Oh, actually over being scratched?
- Yeah, not even a scratch.
If there was like just a
tiny bit of dust on it,
it just wouldn't run.
- I remember there was
disk cleaning services
at game stores.
- [Joey] Really?
- Yeah, yeah, in the UK.
And they just didn't fucking work.
Like, at all.
(Joey laughs)
Like you pay like 30 pounds,
which is the cost of a game at that time,
and you get two disks back
and they just didn't do anything.
It didn't work. They'd be
like, "Yeah, it's good to go."
And I'm like, "No, it's not. I put it in.
Did you even try it?" And
they're like, "Yeah, it worked."
I'm like, "Fuck off, it didn't."
- That's why I like the Super
Nintendo cartridges, right?
'Cause it's like, if it didn't work-
- Cartridges are pretty nice.
- Blow on that bitch,
like smack it against
the wall if you want,
and you pop it in and it magically works.
- Oh, speaking of the cartridges
and things you should never do,
I remember I had a fucking dickhead...
You know, some kids are just dickheads
for absolutely no reason?
- Yeah, of course, of course.
- So we had this distant
relative friend who-
- Who is no longer a friend.
(Joey laughs)
- No, no, no, no.
- He's just a distant relative now.
- You'll hear this story,
'cause, you know, at family reunions,
especially Asian family reunions,
there are some kids there,
some people that you don't
know how you're related to
or your family's related to.
- And they're the worst.
- But it's like a family friend, cousin,
and they're always fucking worse.
So I remember we were playing
"Goldeneye" on the N64.
- I bet he chose Oddjob, didn't he?
- Huh?
- Bet he chose Oddjob.
- No, no, no.
No, no, no, no, he didn't do that.
He got smashed, he got battered,
and he was a pretty young kid.
- (laughs) Schooled him.
- We schooled him.
It was a four player game.
He died immediately.
And he got humiliated.
And what did he do?
He just went over to the N64
and just took the cartridge out.
No turning off the console, no nothing,
just took the cartridge out.
- That's a big no-no.
You can't do that.
- And I'm just like,
you know the debates of
whether people can be born evil
or whether they learn it?
(Joey laughs)
I'm just like, clearly kids are born evil.
Like I'm clearly just witnessing
Johan Liebert right here.
- There are some kids that
you're like, "You, you, ooh,
you must've been born with it.
There's something wrong."
- You came out the womb a bastard.
- I thought there was
fucking music playing
when you came out the fucking womb.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Like "Final Fantasy"
boss music. (laughs)
- I bet Zeromus' theme
played when you came out.
(everyone laughs)
As a kid, and I'm sure you
can understand as well,
like as a gaming kid, right,
you could punch me, you could
spit on me, you could stab me,
but you don't touch the game console.
That's a big no-no.
It doesn't matter how heated shit gets,
you stay away from the PS1.
- That's sacrilegious.
- That's like stuff that...
I was a calm kid at times,
but the one thing that would set me off
is like, "You touch the
game console while it's on,
I'ma lose it. I don't care who you are."
- Yeah, one of my biggest
pet peeves as a kid
whenever I played with a mate or something
or whenever I have mates over
is for some reason everyone
had fucking greasy hands
and their hands would
grease up my controllers.
- No respect for the Dual
Shock PS2 Controller.
- Yeah.
Like my biggest pet
peeve was when, you know,
when we're having food or
something and we had pizza,
and they would be eating the
pizza while playing the game.
- Get a wet wipe.
Get a wet wipe, please.
- (laughs) And I could
see their greasy hands
going on the controller.
And I'm just like, "You know what?
maybe friendship's overrated."
(Connor laughs)
This is why I play single player games.
- And it forms a line of grease
in between the button and the controller.
Oh, yeah, and like physically see it, ugh.
- That's why, you know,
when people grab pizza and
there is kitchen roll available,
I'm like, "You absolute animal.
There was a perfectly good
kitchen roll on the table.
Why did you not take a slice?
You know, for the crumbs, or
just to wipe your hands on?
You know, this is pizza.
It's greasy, come on." (sighs)
- Yeah, never again.
- Yeah, please, please,
learn some manners.
Especially as adults.
'Cause I feel like, even as adults,
there's some people who
don't do that as well.
And, I don't know,
greasy controllers is just
one of my biggest pet peeves.
- Yeah.
- That's pretty disgusting.
'Cause it's kinda hard to
clean a greasy controller.
- Yeah, it is.
- You gotta get that grease
out and it goes in the folds.
Fuck.
- Ugh, gross.
- I was gonna say
something, I totally forgot.
(Joey burps)
You know what was my most
hated genre of video online?
- Video?
- Yeah, yeah, genre of video.
It is the people who turn
people's gaming consoles off
of like 10-year-old kids
while they're playing
and they're like, "Look,
he's getting angry."
Yeah, no shit he's getting angry,
you just turned that shit off.
- I've never heard of that genre of video.
- You must've seen them.
There's tons of videos out there
where people just go up
to their little brother,
turn the game console off or PC off
while they're playing
"Minecraft" or something.
- What a cunt.
- And then they're like, "Haha,
look, he's getting angry."
Yeah, no shit he's getting angry.
He's probably building his fucking world.
- The adulting version of that is like,
if your friend was driving
and then you just pulled
the fucking keys out.
It's like, "Haha, look, he's angry."
It's like, yeah, no shit
he's angry. (laughs)
Dude, he didn't deserve it.
- That's life threatening.
- That's just like, "I'm
about to die." (laughs)
- Yeah, it's an endgame.
- Haha, well, let's die together.
- Well, yeah, to a ten-year-old,
it might as well be fucking
life and death, right?
- I'd rather you pulled the keys out.
- That's true, that's true.
- Right? It's life and death.
So it was a good analogy, fuck you.
(Garnt laughing)
- It's one of those things
where it's like, okay, (laughs)
doing something to, like...
If that kid accidentally turned
off his own PC, that's fine.
If he gets angry, yeah, that's his fault.
He did it.
But when you do it to someone,
you know, it's like, okay,
just 'cause you don't understand the hobby
and you don't understand
how invested someone is,
fuck you, thinking that it's just funny
'cause, oh, you turned it
off, you got a reaction.
Do something else.
What's wrong with you?
How sad is your life?
- Especially when it's unwarranted, right?
- Yeah, how sad is your life
that you have to do this to someone,
that you have to just turn
their game console off
to get some views on
Instagram or something?
Like, fuck off, you're a dickhead.
- Where have you started
seeing these videos?
- Dude, these videos have been
around for decades online.
- I think I'm just like,
avoided watching them.
- Some of most popular
clips back in the day
were brothers turning off
each other's game consoles
while they were playing
and watching their kid rage.
This is a big thing.
- I mean the only one I know
is the kid who got his WoW
account deleted by his mum,
and the boy's freaking out in his bedroom.
- Oh, that's staged though.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, that's staged, but.
- I feel like I've seen some
videos where that's been true.
- You've seen it.
- Yeah, I've seen some of those videos
where just accounts get deleted.
- But like, because obviously now,
'cause TikTok is rising, right?
So I feel like TikTok
has been going through
a lot of the old trends that
happened back in the day.
And I've been seeing it a lot on TikTok.
And I'm like, "This shit isn't funny.
You're just a dickhead."
Like, how are you getting likes for this?
- Was it funny back in the day though,
when you're watching it?
- Yeah, but that's 'cause
the kids would stage it
and they would make
these insane reactions-
- It's funny back in the day
when I was younger. (laughs)
- Yeah, when I was 10-
- I'm older now, and now it
was just a dickhead move.
- When I was 10, I thought it was funny
because I was like, "Oh, this
is great, this is so funny.
The kid's shouting and screaming."
And that now I'm an adult, I'm like...
But then seeing another adult do it,
I'm like, "What's wrong with you?"
(Joey laughs)
If I'm 10, and my 12-year-old
brother did it to me,
that's probably funny to
another 12-year-old me.
- Well, one video genre
that's very similar to that
that I've just never gotten or found funny
is just like people being dickheads
in big stores or something.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
- I remember I used to see it all the time
in Vine and TikTok or something like that.
- There's so many TikTok's like that.
- How are they are being dicks in stores?
- Oh, just like fucking-
- Just being public nuisances.
- Yeah, just being public nuisances.
And it's always something
like a Walmart or a Costco.
- Oh, what were they?
Like the milk challenge
where they'd throw the milk in the air?
- Yeah, the throw the milk in the air
or fucking just, like,
get all the footballs
and just start throwing them everywhere
or just breaking shit.
And it was always be captioned
with the fucking laugh emoji
or something like that.
I'm just like, "Who's funny?
Someone's got to clean up this mess."
'Cause there's always someone
making a mess or something.
I'm just like, dude,
like the fucking employees
are getting paid shit
and they gotta clean up your mess?
- I wish that genre of
videos would just die.
- Yeah.
- But people are just always
desperate to get likes.
- But that's the thing, right?
It's like, I feel that a lot of the times,
those guys just get away with it.
- Oh yeah, absolutely.
- Like if there was like repercussions
for every single person
who was doing that,
I think it would stop,
you know, obviously.
But they just think like, "Haha,
teehee, I just made a mess.
Funny, right?"
- There was a video
trend that went around,
I have no idea why this is a trend at all,
where people used to open
the ice cream containers
and lick it.
- Oh yeah.
- Oh, yeah, I remember that.
- And somebody did get convicted actually.
- Well, yeah, good,
'cause that's disgusting.
- Yeah, it's fucking vile.
That's just so gross.
And I have to sit there and
think what kind of sick fuck
thought of this idea and
thought it was funny.
And then also the person who watched it
and thought, "That's hilarious,
I'm gonna go to that."
What's wrong?
How have we failed every
single parent on this earth?
How have they failed?
There's two people who have the same idea
and thought this was funny.
And then again, after that,
more people find it funny.
How are these people being bred?
- That's just how I feel about
most YouTube or just internet trends.
- There should be like a,
you know when you go to the
doctor to give childbirth,
they should play a series of videos
and ask you, "Is this funny?"
- If you laugh at any of them,
they just deny you. (laughs)
- (laughs) We're taking the kid.
You clearly don't have
the right to raise it.
- Then child services just standing there,
waiting for you to laugh.
It's like, do it, I dare you.
- Next up, we have the
screaming in public challenge.
- Yeah, here you go.
- And then if they laugh a little, ooh.
- Show the Tide Pod challenge,
did you think that was a good idea?
Just making sure.
- How does it make you feel?
- How does it make you feel? (laughs)
- I don't know.
It's so tragic, fuck, man.
- We're a shit person
raw shag test. (laughs)
- That's terrible, man.
- Did you ever find shit
like "Jackass" or something
funny back in the day though?
- Yeah, but that's
'cause I think it was new
and it was unheard of.
And, you know, as well,
when it was on TV, there
was a lot of disconnect.
- Yeah, I feel like
that disconnect from TV
is just gone because there
was always like, I don't know,
it might not have been true, but as a kid,
if it was on TV,
then there was always that disconnect
of like, "Oh, this is maybe staged"
or "They sorted something out"
or "People in that video got
compensation of some form."
- Well, because, you know,
when Jackass did those
stunts in public, you know,
even back then the rules were the same.
You can't just upload any
footage of any person's face.
You have to get a release form.
And so that means that
the person they pranked
clearly signed off on it.
'Cause you have to get the
release form or they're blurred.
And in that case it's like, alright, well-
- I liked "Jackass" back in the day.
But the ones where they
would do shit in public
with just random people in the streets,
I did not like watching those
just because I felt bad for the people
who got involved, right?
But I liked the ones
where they would just
do shit with each other
and just laugh at each other.
Like, those were fucking hilarious, but.
- Yeah.
But, you know, also,
even with "Jackass," right,
a network is signing off on this,
they are following rules, right?
The problem is when people
are doing this in public
and they're doing it on their own-
- They don't know shit.
- There's no rules,
there's no release forms.
there's no procedure around this.
And even if you are gonna prank someone,
you can't just show their face,
you have to get a release
form. Like, it's a mess.
And I think the problem is is that,
because we've seen this on TV,
the younger generation
think that, "Oh, okay,
well, I can just do that."
It's like, no, no, no, not quite, no.
- There's lots of adulting things though-
- There's a reason why
all the big prank channels
fake their pranks,
because it gets to the point where-
- It's almost they can't get away with it.
- Yeah, you can't.
Like, getting release
forms is a nightmare.
And also, you know,
even getting the reactions
you want is a pain in the ass,
and then you forget
that you have to get
them to sign a release.
- Yeah.
And so lot of prank channels
just are dickheads, right?
- Oh, like a lot of them ran into trouble.
Like, I mean Vitaly when he was in prison,
he went to prison in Egypt.
- What did he do?
- He climbed the fucking pyramids.
- [Joey] Oh, yeah, that's right.
I remember that.
- (chuckles) Oh, did he do that?
- Yeah, and then when he got let out,
it was like the worst thing
ever. And then he got out
and then went and beat up some old woman.
He jumped an old woman in
Santa Monica or something.
- He actually went insane, bro.
- Like he nearly killed this woman.
- Fuck, I think-
- Don't do pranks.
- Yeah, 'cause I think
the ones that I remember
was two kids-
- Oh, that was horrible.
- The two brothers who faked a burglary
or something like that,
or faked like a bank robbery?
- Oh, and they got the Uber?
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Then they got the Uber,
and the Uber refused to drive them.
And they were like, "Ha,
what an asshole Uber driver.
He wouldn't drive us."
Nah, it's just like,
what is going on in this world right now?
- And they thought it was hilarious.
- Yeah, and millions of
people found that hilarious.
- It's just tragic, you know?
And, you know, that prank where that,
or not prank,
or that challenge where that guy tried
to see if a book could stop
a desert eagle or something,
which, you know, you can't help but laugh
at how stupid that sounds.
- And girlfriend literally
shot the boyfriend.
- Yeah, and she killed him.
And it's like, this is tragic.
'cause like, you know,
people are obviously getting these ideas
from watching this shit online.
It's fucking terrible.
I think pranks are a genre that
should just die on YouTube.
Any prank that isn't a
very, just chill prank
on someone you know,
you know, those pranks
are hilarious, right?
- The ones that always end
with the person getting pranked laughing
is, you know, the ones
that are fine because-
- You spray your housemate with water,
you put a pie on their face, whatever,
that's all good fun, you know?
But like, I just think when
you're doing it to strangers
and they have no say,
and it's something that could hurt them
or it's something that
could genuinely scare them,
you could be traumatized
with some of these pranks.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- So fuck that, no.
- Just like, don't be
an asshole, basically.
It's such a fine line because, you know,
the line between asshole-
- A lot of these people are psychopaths.
They don't know what that doing-
- Yeah, exactly, a lot of
people are psychopaths.
- They have no fucking idea.
- And, you know,
unfortunately we live in a
climate where a lot of times
being an asshole gives you good-
- You're rewarded, yeah.
- You get rewarded for it.
It's unfortunate.
- Man, we're just growing
into old bitchy old men,
aren't we?
(Joey chuckles)
- Jesus.
- Wow, man,
I don't know
if it's because I've just
been on YouTube so long, man.
Some genres, I don't like to be elitist
and look down on genres of YouTube,
but pranks is one of the
genres that need to die.
- Yeah, but then I do. (laughs)
- But then I suddenly will towards pranks.
Pranks are a genre that
should have died long ago.
- I mean, and luckily they
have, I feel, in a lot of ways.
I mean, they've died on
YouTube, but now they've just-
- I think they've just migrated to TikTok.
- TikTok is gonna redo it.
- They migrated to TikTok.
- They started on YouTube
and then Vine was also,
there was so many prank Vines as well.
And then now I think
they've just both migrated
to TikTok as well and it's just-
- I've been watching a
lot of YouTube Shorts
and I just lose my mind
watching the stuff.
- Why are you watching...
Of who?
- Dunno, it pops up and I watch them.
Some of them are funny, some
of them are pretty good,
but obviously they're just all re-posts.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But there's some genre
videos that I just think,
I absolutely despise to death.
And one of them is like,
there's this genre and I
don't understand it at all.
There's this video and
there's this guy, right?
Imagine that your phone
is vertical, whatever,
it's cut into two.
There'll be one video of the guy
explaining the video that
is about to play before you.
- [Joey] Okay.
- That is very self-explanatory.
So there's one where there was this video,
and this guy's like,
"Here are the different types of Pokemon
compared to each other in size."
And he goes like, "Pikachu, one meter.
Snorlax, one meter."
And it's like, I did not need
you to tell me what this is,
and I don't need you to sit
there for 10 seconds like this,
while the video is playing
after you've explained what it is.
- (laughs) Oh, he's still on screen?
- He's still on screen the whole time.
He's just sitting there.
And then he'll go like, "Whoa, that's big.
Whoa, I didn't expect
that Pokemon to be big."
And it's like, "What is this?
What is this?"
- That's infuriating.
- You stole someone else's
video, you re-posted it-
- Oh, it's not even his video?
- No.
No, of course it's not his video.
And they just re-post it.
And it's like, this is shit.
This is the worst type of content.
I hate this so much.
- It's literally just stealing.
- I just hate it, man,
and, yeah, it's terrible.
- Reaction 2.0, the evolution.
- 'Cause, yeah, that's what it is.
Instead of like-
- It's reaction videos
with somehow less effort.
- Yeah, they've made reaction videos
that are somehow worse
than reaction videos
where they're like, not even reacting.
It's like, "Hey, I'm gonna explain to you
what the video is gonna explain to you."
- They're literally just
a talking description box.
That's all it is.
- I immediately skipped them whenever,
or any financial advice
ones, I skip immediately.
(Joey chuckles)
There's a lot of those.
There's a lot of ones
that start off with inspirational music.
You'll be scrolling and you'll
hear the inspirational music.
- "Here's how I made my
first million dollars."
- They're like, "Sir, why are
you working for $10 an hour?"
And it's like, I know where this is going.
And it's like, "I work for $1,000 an hour.
Do you know why?
I value my time."
And it's like, oh my fucking God.
The sheer amount of guru stuff
on TikTok and YouTube Shorts, it's insane.
It's way out of control.
- Well, yeah, I mean, it's going-
- Poor kids who are gonna think
that everyone should be
earning 10 grand a minute,
you know what I mean?
They go back to their dad, you know,
and the kid's like, "What do
you wanna do for Christmas?"
Or "What do you want to do
for the rest of your life?"
Kid comes in with a
fucking Bluetooth headset,
"Dad, I've already started
making $10,000 an hour
from drop-shipping online.
You know, the fact that
you're working at your job
is actually kind of cringe, Dad."
(Joey laughs)
You know what I mean?
It's like, we're gonna have
a whole generation of kids
raised like this.
This is tragic.
- Yeah, I know.
- Or in fucking kindergartens,
like putting down what they
wanna be when they grow up,
and everyone puts entrepreneur.
(everyone laughing)
Entrepreneur.
- Dad's like, "What do you
want for Christmas, son?"
"Dad, why haven't you invested in my 401k?
This is embarrassing."
- So when you grow up,
where would you like to go?
Silicon Valley.
It's the only destination.
- It's fucking absurd.
It's so stupid, man.
- Jesus Christ.
- I can't stand it.
- Just do what you want, man.
Just do what you want.
- There's a lot of really
funny stuff though on there,
but you have to siphon and
shovel through so much shit
to find some good TikToks and Shorts.
- That's why I just wait for them
to eventually get onto Twitter.
- Yeah.
- You know, if they make their
way on YouTube compilations
or Twitter,
which is how I consume most of my TikTok,
because I did actually try
downloading TikTok the other day
and I gave it a go.
And I was just like, "Oh, it's just..."
I don't have enough
patience for the algorithm
to find what I really like,
'cause there's so much
shit you go through.
Like, it's so weird
seeing some of the TikToks that are there.
'Cause I remember going
through anime TikTok, right,
and seeing, okay,
I am an anime YouTuber by trade.
I wonder what anime TikTok is up to.
- That was your first mistake. (laughs)
Asking that question.
- So there was this like
really, really weird trend
that was going on,
which is the silhouette
trend or something like that.
- Oh, fuck.
- I remember that shit.
- Okay, okay,
so you know what I'm talking about?
- I know what you're talking about.
- Well, where these girls or
guys would basically pretend
that they were making out
with a silhouette of a
character or something, right?
And one of the-
- That shit's funny.
- But it's just like, it's 100% serious.
- It's ironic.
- Oh.
- It's ironically funny.
- Oh, I thought it was a joke.
- No, no, no, no.
- No, no, it's 100%.
- It would be funny if it was a joke.
- I thought it was a joke.
- It's 100% serious
where you just pretend
you're making out with someone, right?
And it's like, there's no irony to it.
It is just that.
And I remember I was browsing anime TikTok
I saw a clip which had
millions and millions of views
on this clip,
and it's this girl who's
pretending to make out
with a silhouette of Bakugo.
And they literally put
in sound clips of the dub
to make it seem like he's
in a dominating fashion
for this TikTok.
- Oh my god.
- And I'm just like, "I
must be getting old,"
'cause I remember if you did this
when I was an anime fan growing up,
you'd get bullied for this shit.
- You would get crucified.
- Like this is the type of shit
people got internet bullied for, man.
- I like the JoJo pose one,
where it's like, "JoJo."
- JoJo pose, that one was cool.
- That one was cool.
- That's cool.
- Some of them are insane.
- Yeah,
because there was either people
who were just really good at JoJo posing,
but then there were other
people who took that
and put a spin on it
with all sorts of different
anime and stuff like that.
That's fine.
But that shit is the
same as like, you know,
like laughing at those
is the same as laughing
at, back in the day,
of watching people proposing at anime cons
and stuff like that, right?
Like, that trend of video,
it's just like kind of coming back,
but now it's just on TikTok now.
- Yeah.
- It's just so weird
seeing these things
trending and being popular
because I just remember thinking, wow,
this is so much different
to being an anime fan
when I was fucking growing up.
- Yeah, they re-post anime
scenes and play different music,
and I'm like, "What is this?
I don't wanna watch this shit."
I've seen this re-post
of this one anime scene
a million times,
and it's some samurai versus a lumberjack.
- [Joey] What?
- And they're fighting each other.
- Okay.
- And I've seen this scene re-posted
on YouTube and TikTok and
stuff a million times.
I still don't know what it's from,
but I've seen this fight,
like a million times.
And it's always on TikTok, I don't get it.
- Is it good at all?
- Yeah, it's pretty cool.
- Okay, well, that's fine.
- But that's it, they
just keep re-posting it.
I don't get it.
- At least it's not the samurai
and lumberjack making out,
right, in the silhouette
challenge. (laughs)
- Maybe, it could be.
(Garnt laughs)
- Next TikTok idea.
- I don't know, maybe we should do it.
- It's free real estate, take it.
- We'll do the silhouette challenge.
- It gave me the same reaction as,
you know that animation of
Sonic and Mario making out?
- I love that one.
- (laughs) I love that one.
- That's a great fucking clip, bro.
- It's so funny.
- That one has so many
layers to it though,
you know what I mean?
- It's the fiery passion
at which Mario and Sonic are making out,
and Sonic rips off Mario's shirt
in such a passionate way
that makes me feel like they are in love.
- It's so funny.
- It's amazing.
- God, yeah.
I don't know, man, like I
tried dallying in TikTok
because Aki uses TikTok quite a bit.
- We sound like Boomers here.
I'm trying to get an
understanding of these kids here,
but I just can't do it.
- I tried it, I tried it.
'Cause I saw it was getting so big,
so I was like, "Alright,
well, then, you know."
Because it is getting so big,
there might be a chance one of these days
where I might have to
start using it, right?
- I scrolled through it
and I just feel like I'm losing my mind.
- [Joey] Yeah, right?
- I feel like my mind is going
numb, watching this stuff,
'cause it's so fast-paced.
You don't get a chance to do anything.
You don't get a chance to think.
You're just, "Alright, next, next, next.
- It's like literally
just constantly just
watching Instagram stories.
I'm like, I can't do it.
It's too much information.
- I never felt like
I was in like a "Black Mirror" thing
until I was watching
YouTube Shorts and TikTok,
'cause you're not even
watching the videos,
you're just consuming the videos.
And you scroll to the next
one, scroll to the next one.
You don't even think, you
just scroll, keep scrolling.
And on YouTube, at least
you have that thing of like,
"Well, I'm gonna look what I wanna watch.
Oh, doesn't look good.
Okay, refresh the homepage.
Alright, refresh the homepage."
You know, you have to actually think
what you're about to watch.
But on TikTok and Shorts,
they just feed it to you
and you don't think.
It's weird, right?
Like I feel like we're
getting to the point
where content is being
forced down your throat.
It's not where you're choosing
to watch what you want.
- Right, right, right.
- It's very strange.
- I mean, there's some content on TikTok
which was just so weird
'cause it was almost like hypnotic.
Because there's some content
that has just had obviously
millions of millions of views
and it's just some very
oddly satisfying thing
or something, I don't know.
It's so hard to describe why I was like,
not invested, but just
like, intrigued by it.
But I wouldn't call it
interesting content,
it was just like, "Ooh, that's a-
- Entranced, couldn't take your eyes away.
- That's a bit interesting.
Alright, and next.
Oh, okay, that's pretty good.
- Right, right.
- I was never emotionally
invested in any of this content,
which is why it kind of felt
like almost hypnotic in a way.
- Because it doesn't give you the time
to get emotionally invested, right,
because it's over in six seconds.
- Yeah.
The only funny TikToks I've seen
have been TikToks that
have just made its way
into Twitter or YouTube compilations.
- That's the thing, yeah, yeah.
- Like, on TikTok, I don't
know what I'm doing wrong.
How do I make-
- How do you TikTok?
- How do I make TikTok good?
I wanna know.
I wanna know where to find a good content.
- Like you can't search for anything.
Like, you can, but you'd have
to sift through just like...
If you look up like a hashtag, right,
if you happen to find one,
or an audio file or something
that you thought was kind of
funny that's being used, right,
you can search for that.
But in order to find the actual good shit,
you just have to sift through
so much unrelated shit.
- I had a few audios
of mine get pretty big
from my YouTube videos.
And I was just like,
"What the fuck is this?"
Because it was like really bizarre things.
Like there was one where it was about me,
like sucking dick or
something, and cosplaying.
And there were so many people
who used it to make TikToks,
I was so confused.
'Cause it was like these
13-year-old kids being like,
"There's no time to talk.
I need to wear cosplay and
suck dick or something."
And I'm like, "Is this okay?
What is going on?
I'm so confused."
And I was like, "Okay, uh,
hopefully people don't watch my videos
'cause some of these
kids are really young."
What the fuck?
- Yeah.
- It's funny though. It was cool.
- Yeah, I've had a couple of TikToks
where they've used my audio.
- I like it though. I
think it's interesting.
- Yeah, no, it's really cool
because it's like, "Oh, you know,
that's kind of flattering that
they thought it was funny,"
I think I said.
- I just feel like a
dodo when I look at it.
I'm like, "What's going on?"
- Yeah, but at the same time,
I'm like, "That's cool."
But at the same time I
look at it, I'm like,
"Why are you doing this?" (laughs)
- I was thinking,
I was like, "Surely I've
said other things in audio
that are more entertaining
and more useful than this."
- Of all the things I've said,
you thought this was
the funniest? (laughs)
- I mean, that's how
the internet is, right?
It just takes things off, I don't know.
- I don't know, it weird.
- We don't know how to TikTok.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, have you ever legitimately
thought of being like,
"I need to start a TikTok"?
- Yeah, no.
- Because there's lots
of YouTubers right now
who are starting TikToks now
and kind of getting into it, right?
- I don't know.
I'm not convinced the TikTok audience is,
well, the demographic I want.
- Right.
- I don't know, I like the
demographic I have right now.
I like just chilling, doing
my own thing, streaming games.
- I mean, I think we've grown up,
we've made an audience
that like us for us,
luckily enough, and like
the content we make.
I don't feel like I need to move myself
on a different platform
just because that platform
is getting popular, right?
It's kinda like-
- Yeah, we've definitely grown with...
Our audience has grown with us, right?
- Yeah, it's kinda like why
I get so many messages about this,
about, "Garnt, why
don't you use Instagram?
Why don't you post more on Instagram?"
(Joey and Connor laughing)
- Why don't you?
- Yeah, why don't you?
- It's the simple answer of
I'm shit at taking photos, okay?
(Joey laughs)
I just forget to document my life.
I'm sorry, okay?
- I feel that, I feel that.
- That's why I get my
girlfriend to take photos of me
'cause I'm so shit at taking
photos of myself. (laughs)
- And it's just like, you know,
you get brands coming
to you, being like, "Oh,
Instagram got the most
viewers and the most audience
and the biggest numbers."
And I'm just like, well,
is that really valuable?
Just going on a platform
just because it's got big
numbers and a big audience?
As a content creator,
I find it's way more valuable,
even if you're promoting
to a smaller audience,
that it's an audience
that is more suitable
for the stuff that you're making, right?
So I'm not gonna make a TikTok
just because it's popular,
unless I think I actually like TikTok,
or I think I can make good TikToks,
because otherwise I'm gonna
get a bunch of audience
that I don't understand.
- Yeah, that's true.
What's going on?
Why are you here?
- And then I will literally
be the Boomer then.
You know, and just like,
"Oh, let's connect with the kids.
Everyone's having a TikTok nowadays."
- Here's my TikTok of me
making out with Bakugo.
(everyone laughing)
- Maybe I would take off that.
Maybe I could do it.
- Garnt making out with Bakugo. (laughs)
But you know who else has a TikTok
or who doesn't have a TikTok?
Our Patreons.
I don't know,
I tried to fucking use TikTok.
- That was a terrible outro.
Shout out to the Patreons that
are on the screen right now
who don't do terrible outros.
- I tried to somehow segue it from TikTok,
it just didn't work.
- That was the worst segue.
- That was probably the worst one.
- Yeah, I was like, you know
that group of audience members
that do this thing but
also don't this thing?
These guys.
- Pretty sure you rode the segue
and just fucking crashed
it into a train, man.
- Crashed into the fucking wall.
- Right off a cliff, I went.
But, hey, if you like to join the Patreon
and support the show,
then make sure to go over to our Patreon,
patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also follow us on Twitter,
send us your memes on the subreddit,
and if you hate our face,
listen to us on Spotify.
- And, yeah, that's been
pretty much the Boomer episode
of "Trash Taste."
(Joey laughing)
We are getting old.
- Fuck, bro, I'm 25, man.
Quarter of a century
old, I prefer to say it.
- Wow.
- Look at this baby.
Look at this baby.
- I've probably aged mentally the most.
(Garnt laughs)
- Yeah,
you are the closest to death, man.
- I've been considering
getting a lawnmower
that I can sit on.
(Joey laughs)
- To be fair,
there are times where I'm like,
"That looks lit." (laughs)
- Oh, you know if I'm getting a lawn,
I'm getting a lawnmower I can sit on.
- Hell yeah, dude.
- With a slot for my TikTok phone enabled.
- (laughs) So I can watch all the people
making out with Bakugo (laughs)
as I'm mowing my lawn.
- On my OLED 4K phone.
- You know the first time I felt old?
The first time I-
- It's like a bonus "Trash Taste."
- A bonus "Trash Taste."
We're over, but I just
need to say this, man.
The first time I got excited
about buying furniture,
I was like, "Yep, it's over for me."
But now that I'm moving,
goddamn, I'm so excited to
refurnish my place, man.
- I got a couch, oh.
- Dude, when that new
washing machine came in,
I was like, "Dude, fuck the
hype I felt for all these games.
This is where the real
hype is that, dude."
Hell yeah.
- I'm excited to cable manage.
I can't wait to do it properly.
I've done it wrong.
Anyway-
- Are you keeping up with us, kids?
- Anyway, we'll continue this
on the next "Trash Taste"
when we are moved in.
- Thanks for watching, guys,
and we'll see you next time.
- [Everyone] Bye.
(gentle music)